la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
le sujet dont nous nous apprêtons à
débattre est essentiel il est l'objet
d'interrogations de discussion et
parfois de passion
parler d'immigration c'est parler de
trajectoire personnelle ou familiale
c'est parler de nos valeurs de notre
droit et de notre histoire
notre pays a toujours accueilli et
intégré toujours délivré des titres de
ces jours avec des périodes d'arrivée
parfois plus marquées parfois moins
soutenu la France est restera fidèle à
sa tradition d'asile mais il est
légitime de se poser la question de
notre politique migratoire dire qui on
veut qui on peut accueillir et qui on ne
veut pas qui on ne peut pas accueillir
débattre d'immigration ce n'est pas se
limiter à un sujet la question renvoie
aux causes profondes des mouvements
migratoires à l'efficacité des
politiques de développement pour lutter
contre la proposeté ou les conséquences
du changement climatique et à
l'indispensable coopération avec les
pays d'origine et de transit elle est
liée à nos frontières et à la manière
dont nous devons les faire respecter
elle interroge l'efficacité de nos
procédures juridiques et de notre droit
elle soulève la question centrale de
l'intégration
dans quelques semaines le gouvernement
présentera un texte sur notre politique
migratoire les ministres reviendront
dans un instant sur ces principes
directeurs
pour construire ce projet de loi
plusieurs ministres sont en effet
mobilisés et une large concertation est
en cours je l'avais annoncé dès cet été
le ministre de l'Intérieur la conduit
avec l'appui de la secrétaire d'État à
la citoyenneté le ministre du Travail
c'est également engagé pour discuter des
mesures concernant son champ nous
voulons que le futur texte prolonge les
améliorations de la loi Asie
l'immigration votez lors du premier
quinquennat nous voulons qu'il adapte
notre droit aux évolutions et défis
actuels de la question migratoire
en un mot nous visons l'efficacité les
mesures utiles et les effets concrets
nous ne cherchons pas à cliver ou à
multiplier des mesures uniquement
symboliques ce texte sera équilibré nous
restons fidèles à nos valeurs et à notre
volonté d'intégrer mais on ne peut
intégrer dignement que si notre droit
est respecté fermement
il me paraissait donc important
essentiel même avant la finalisation du
projet de loi et comme je m'y étais
engagé de venir devant la représentation
nationale pour vous présenter des faits
des orientations et pour en débattre
présenter des faits d'abord parce que ce
débat ne peut se reposer sur des
impressions ou des peurs je le dis
d'emblée l'immigration zéro n'est ni
souhaitable ni possible pas plus
réaliste que ne l'est une immigration
déréguréulée ces promesses illusoires
sont mensongères démagogiques et
dangereuses
particulièrement à l'extrême droite
c'est 12 derniers mois ont été
foisonnants en contre-vérité et en
propose la fermeté ça n'est pas la haine
de l'autre le respect de nos frontières
ce n'est pas le repli et l'intégration
pleine et entière de ce que nous
accueillons c'est le devoir de notre
pays
nous aurons des désaccords
c'est la démocratie mais c'est des
accords doivent émerger sur la base de
fées alors Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés commençons par là commençons par
les faits
d'abord oui il existe une immigration
légale je le dis car à entendre certains
on l'oublierait cette immigration légale
ce sont des salariés qualifiés ou encore
les personnes que les Françaises et les
Français ont choisi d'épouser
j'entends souvent dire que le nombre de
titres délivrés à progresser
c'est juste la tendance ne date pas
d'hier et elle s'est vérifiée sous des
majorités de gauche comme de droite
ainsi en 15 ans le nombre de titres de
séjour délivrés est passé de façon
progressive de 172
000 en 2007 à 271 000 en 2021
mais ne nous trompons pas sur les causes
de cette augmentation
contrairement aux caricatures
l'immigration familiale a baissé sur
cette période s'il y a eu une
augmentation c'est pour trois raisons
d'abord parce que notre enseignement
supérieur est attractif et que depuis
2017 le nombre d'étudiants que nous
accueillons à doubler c'est une bonne
nouvelle ces étudiants apprennent à
parler français à connaître notre pays
et le font rayonner dans le monde
deuxième raison de cette hausse le
nombre de salariés qualifiés et de
chercheurs que nous accueillons à
augmenter en 15 ans et cela a bénéficié
à notre économie à nos entreprises et à
notre innovation
enfin dernière raison de cette hausse
l'augmentation modérée du nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'asile ce sont 30 000
personnes menacées dans leur pays que
nous accueillons chaque année c'est
l'honneur de la France de leur donner
leur place c'est l'honneur de notre pays
d'avoir accueilli 3000 ressortissants
afghan juste après la chute de Kaboul
l'an dernier c'est l'honneur de la
France d'avoir accueilli 108 000
Ukrainiens depuis le 24 février dernier
sous le statut de protection temporaire
au nom du gouvernement je tiens à
remercier l'OFPRA les élus locaux les
associations et les employeurs qui les
accompagnent au quotidien
bien sûr nous devons donner à toutes les
personnes arriver légalement les moyens
d'une intégration digne et complète
certaines difficultés existent encore
notamment en termes d'insertion
professionnelle j'y reviendrai
je veux encore tordre le cou à une
dernière idée reçue non l'aide médicale
d'État ne nourrit pas l'immigration
irrégulière c'est une question de
protection et de santé publique aucun
projet migratoire vers la France n'est
seulement motivé par l'existence de ce
dispositif dans les conditions d'accès
et les modalités de contrôle ont été
renforcées récemment
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
quels sont les faits concernant
l'immigration légale mais le principal
en jeu ça n'est pas tant la situation de
ceux à qui nous avons délivré un titre
que celle des personnes qui se
maintiennent sur notre territoire sans y
avoir droit ces personnes ne sont pas
éligibles à l'asile il aura souvent été
explicitement refusé pourtant le flux de
demande augmente nettement ces dernières
années et celles et ceux à qui nous
n'accordons pas la protection reste
encore trop fréquemment sur notre
territoire
souvent victime de passeurs qui leur
promettent l'Eldorado et mettent en
danger leur vie la plupart d'entre eux
vivent dans la grande précarité sont
disposés du droit à travailler et
parfois sombre dans la délinquance
face à ce défi les amateurs de solutions
toutes faites sont nombreuses on trouve
les partisans du Yaka faucon qui
voudraient renvoyer d'un seul coup d'un
seul l'intégralité d'entre eux oui je
souhaite que le droit et nos frontières
soient respectés oui je souhaite des
éloignements rapides et efficaces des
personnes en situation irrégulière mais
non on ne peut pas prétendre que les
choses soient simples comme si nous
pouvions nous affranchir de
l'indispensable coopération des pays
d'origine et des règles de l'État de
droit de l'autre côté certains appellent
à des opérations de régularisation
massive je le dis aussi clairement il
n'en n'est pas question nous ne créerons
pas de telles précédents qui ne
régleraient pas les difficultés des
personnes concernées qui donneraient des
arguments au passeur et qui ne seraient
ni accepté ni acceptable par les
français pour notre part nous voulons
prendre le sujet à bras le corps et
proposer des solutions utiles et
efficaces
je crois que nous pouvons nous retrouver
sur une préoccupation commune évitez que
des étrangers restent durablement dans
une situation indéterminée qui ne serait
ni le droit au séjour ni l'éloignement
aussi nous voulons clarifier beaucoup
plus vite la situation des étrangers
arrivés sur notre sol d'une part nous
voulons accélérer les procédures
d'examens des demandes d'asile et du
droit au séjour pour lutter contre les
pratiques dilatoires et d'autre part une
fois la situation clarifiée nous
souhaitons éloigner plus rapidement ce
qui doivent l'être quant aux personnes
qui ont vocation à rester nous voulons
engager plutôt les actions pour réussir
leur intégration d'abord par la langue
et par l'emploi
c'est principe sont les grands axes de
travail du gouvernement ce sont des
objectifs qui je le crois peuvent
rassembler largement sur ses bancs
mesdames et messieurs les députés comme
l'a dit le président de la République
nous devons déployer une action complète
cohérente et efficace en amont des flux
migratoires et après l'arrivée sur notre
territoire
nous voulons d'abord prévenir les
départs irréguliers en contribuant grâce
à notre aide publique au développement à
traiter les causes profondes des
migrations que sont la pauvreté et de
plus en plus les effets du dérèglement
climatique la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères il reviendra
ensuite nous devons mieux protéger nos
frontières pour y parvenir notre premier
levier d'action est européen
pendant la présidence française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne nous
sommes parvenus à plusieurs avancées
autour du pacte sur la migration et
l'asile en particulier pour rendre plus
efficace les contrôles à l'arrivée en
Europe et pour renforcer les mécanismes
de solidarité pour les états de première
entrée pourvu que ces états respectent
le droit maritime nous devrons notamment
tirer toutes les conséquences de
l'accueil de Lucian viking
nous devons maintenant continuer nous
poussons pour un renforcement des moyens
de Frontex et pour une réforme de
l'espace Schengen nous voulons également
consolider le système d'asile européen
c'est aussi à l'échelle européenne que
nous lutterons plus efficacement contre
les réseaux de passeurs le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colonna et la secrétaire
d'État en charge de l'Europe Laurence
Boone sont pleinement mobilisés en ce
sens
le deuxième moyen d'action c'est au
niveau national en renforçant le
contrôle à nos frontières et en
accélérant les procédures en novembre
2020 le président de la République a
annoncé le doublement des effectifs à
nos frontières et une nouvelle fois les
résultats sont là 10 000 refus par mois
ont été prononcés en 2021 contre 3000
débuts 2020 avant le covid ensuite nous
devons accélérer les procédures
d'examens des demandes d'asile dans ce
domaine des progrès ont été réalisés
dans le précédent quinquennat les délais
de l'OFPRA ont considérablement diminué
mais ceux des procédures contentieuses
sont encore trop longs au total le délai
moyen de traitement d'une demande
d'asile est encore de l'ordre d'un an
nous devons donc accélérer et viser un
délai global de 6 mois pour l'ensemble
de la procédure nous voulons notamment
réformer le contentieux des étrangers
pour le réduire et le simplifier nous
voulons passer de 12 procédures
contentieuses à 4 suivant en cela les
présentation du Conseil d'État et du
rapport du président de la commission
des Lois du Sénat François Noël buffet
le ministre de l'Intérieur il reviendra
et travaillent également avec le
ministre de la Justice
Eric Dupond-Moretti à une réforme de la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile enfin
nous voulons éloigner plus
systématiquement et plus efficacement
les personnes déboutées du droit d'asile
nous devons augmenter nos capacités en
centre de rétention administrative et
nous continuerons à agir dans nos
relations bilatérales avec les pays qui
refusent de réadmettre leur propre
ressortissants
par ailleurs nous devons être
intraitables avec les étrangers
délinquants même en situation régulière
s'engager dans la délinquance c'est se
placer en dehors de notre communauté
nationale c'est porter une atteinte
grave à notre pacte social et à nos
compatriotes c'est également nuit à tous
les étrangers qui vivent en France et
qui construisent paisiblement des
parcours d'intégration réussie dont on
ne parle pas grâce à l'action déterminée
du ministre de l'Intérieur et des
préfets plus de 3000 étrangers auteurs
de troubles à l'ordre public ont été
éloignés en 2021 et 2022 enfin sous le
contrôle du juge et dans le respect de
nos engagements conventionnels des
mesures d'expulsion doivent désormais
pouvoir être prises contre les étrangers
quel que soit leur situation qui
commettent des infractions graves
mesdames et messieurs les députés je le
disais nous portons une vision
équilibrée si nous voulons que ceux qui
ne doivent pas rester partout c'est
aussi pour pouvoir mieux intégrer ce que
nous accueillons cela passe d'abord par
une refonte en profondeur de l'accueil
en préfecture pour les démarches de
renouvellement des titres des étrangers
en situation régulière
nous devons éviter les pertes de droit
notamment d'emploi que peuvent connaître
certaines personnes faute d'accès au
guichet
pour les demandeurs d'asile nous devons
aussi continuer à renforcer nos
capacités d'hébergement en cinq ans nous
les avons déjà augmentés de plus de
36000 places enfin le pivot de notre
politique d'intégration c'est le travail
dans un pays dont le taux de chômage et
de 7,3% nous devons d'abord chercher à
pourvoir les postes vacants en proposant
ses emplois à nous ressortissants et aux
personnes en situation régulière le taux
d'emploi des immigrés en France et 9
points plus faibles que celui de
l'ensemble de la population nous devons
travailler à réduire cet écart ensuite
si les employeurs ne sont pas parvenus à
trouver la main d'oeuvre dont ils ont
besoin ils peuvent la faire venir de
manière légale un employeur peut
toujours solliciter une autorisation de
travail s'il démontre qu'il n'a pas pu
pour voir le poste en déposant une
oeuvre une offre auprès de Pôle Emploi
pour certains métiers particulièrement
en tension l'employeur est même dispensé
de cette justification et nous avons
simplifié ces dis en 2019 pour mieux
répondre aux besoins enfin la question
de la régularisation peut se poser pour
des personnes en situation irrégulière
présente sur notre sol depuis des années
et qui travaille depuis longtemps et
avant que l'extrême droite ne tente une
nouvelle manipulation je le redis il ne
s'agit en aucun cas d'une régularisation
massive ni de laisser penser que la
régularisation serait la réponse aux
tensions sur le marché du travail il
s'agit de régulariser certaines
personnes qui de contribuent depuis
longtemps à la richesse nationale mais
qui subissent parfois des conditions de
travail indignes et restent enfermés
dans un statut précaire
le ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
il reviendra plus en détail enfin
mesdames et messieurs les députés
s'intégrer c'est parler la langue de la
République alors que nous proposons des
cours de langue dès l'arrivée sur le
territoire nous souhaitons qu'un niveau
minimal de Français soit désormais
imposé pour obtenir des titres de séjour
de plus d'un an
mesdames et messieurs les députés
cherchez des mesures efficaces vouloir
une immigration régulée maîtrisée ça
n'est ni manquait de fermeté ni manquait
d'humanité c'est l'expression de notre
volonté de voir nos frontières et notre
doigt droit respecter c'est
l'intransigence face à ceux qui se place
en dehors des lois de la République mais
c'est aussi la fidélité à nos valeurs et
à notre histoire c'est accueillir et
intégrer celles et ceux qui sont menacés
ou victimes de persécution ou encore
celles et ceux qui contribuent au
rayonnement et à la vitalité économique
de notre pays cet équilibre s'accommode
mal des postures politiciennes ils
demandent du travail et des réflexions
sérieuses et de bonne foi il demande des
discussions fondées sur les faits et non
pas sur les peurs il demande la
recherche de solutions efficaces au-delà
des dogmes et des idéologies cet
équilibre c'est la condition pour
creuser le sillon de notre l'histoire et
atteindre l'objectif que nous
recherchons tous l'intégration de celles
et ceux que nous accueillons si nous
acceptons ces principes je suis certaine
que nous pourrons trouver cet équilibre
soyons à la hauteur de l'enjeu je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les députés
madame la Première ministre a rappelé la
situation actuelle en des termes très
clairs le phénomène migratoire est aussi
un enjeu international et donc un enjeu
de politique étrangère notre action
diplomatique à cet égard tient en trois
principes organisation des mobilités
légales dans une logique d'attractivité
des talents
solidarité avec les plus vulnérables et
fermeté face au flux irréguliers et à
ceux qui les exploitent
premier axe les visas sont un outil clé
au service de politique d'influence et
d'attractivité le nombre des étudiants
étrangers par exemple inscrits dans le
système d'enseignement supérieur
français vient d'enregistrer un record
en passant le cap des 400 000 inscrits
en France en 2021 2022 et je dois vous
dire que c'est bon pour notre économie
puisqu'ils importe plus qu'il ne coûte
bon pour l'image de notre pays et bon
pour notre influence
nous devons aussi pouvoir attirer les
talents dont nous avons besoin c'est la
mobilité des chercheurs des artistes des
entrepreneurs des scientifiques comme de
l'ensemble des talents étrangers qui
font rayonner notre pays dans le monde
entier et que nous encourageons via un
dispositif qui s'appelle le passeport
talent qui compte déjà pour l'année 2022
12000 visa
plus généralement nos efforts
d'attractivité doivent aussi servir les
secteurs ou les besoins de main d'oeuvre
sont les plus importants et il y en a
le deuxième principe de notre action
c'est la solidarité c'est une question
d'humanité de fidélité à nos valeurs et
de respect du droit international
consacré par les conventions de Genève
la France coparana ainsi l'an prochain
le Forum mondial des réfugiés avec le
Haut Commissariat des Nations Unies pour
les réfugiés
c'est ainsi que 4 millions et demi ont
obtenu la protection temporaire sur le
sol européen il nous en accueillons plus
de 100 000 en France dont 20 000 enfants
qui sont scolarisés nous pouvons être
fiers de l'accueil que nous le réservons
ainsi qu'aux citoyens afghan vous l'avez
dit madame la Première ministre russes
ou autre menacé dans leur pays
notre politique des visa nous permet
d'accueillir les personnes persécutées
pour leurs activités en faveur de la
liberté de
leurs opinions simplement par ce
qu'elles sont et c'est l'honneur de la
France que de le faire comme la
justement rappelé madame la Première
ministre
la solidarité et l'attractivité vont de
pair avec la fermeté face aux migrations
illégales qui est le troisième principe
de notre action
pour cela nous devons agir au niveau
européen et prolonger les impulsions
données par la présidente française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne qui a
débloqué les discussions autour du pacte
sur l'asile et l'immigration en
réaffirmant deux principes la
responsabilité renforcée des pays de
première entrée et la solidarité des
autres États membres
nous devons également mobiliser les pays
partenaires à notre initiative la
Commission européenne à Laura désormais
près de 10% de ses moyens d'intervention
à l'extérieur 10% à des projets liés aux
migrations
et sur le sujet des réadmissions la
Commission prévoit que des mesures
puissent être prises à l'égard des pays
qui ne coèrent pas suffisamment
madame la Première ministre l'a évoqué
la France s'appuie aussi sur son aide
publique au développement pour agir sur
les causes profondes des migrations
la trajectoire ambitieuse de notre
République au développement renforce
encore nos leviers tout comme l'adoption
d'une nouvelle stratégie migration et
développement
ces stratégie permettra notamment à nos
partenaires du Sud de mieux se doter des
capacités dont ils ont besoin pour
maîtriser les flux et développer une
meilleure gouvernance des migrations
mais aussi de prendre en compte les
effets du changement climatique
que nous les aidons par ailleurs à
traiter dans le cas de la finance climat
qui a progressé lors de la dernière
réunion de la COP en Égypte
notre République au développement
permettra aussi de renforcer la
protection des migrants et de lutter
contre les filières d'immigration
clandestine le trafic et la traite
d'être humain qui sont des activités
abjectes autant que rémunératrice mais
permettra aussi de faciliter les
migrations légales et de dissuader le
départ de ceux qui se jettent sur les
routes de la misère pour tenter de
rejoindre l'Europe parfois je dirais
même souvent au prix de leur vie à cette
égard nous sommes déterminés à faire
preuve de la fermeté nécessaire je vous
remercie
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald de Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
députés
le peuple français est un composé
c'est mieux que race c'est une nation
unique en Europe la conformation de la
France se prêtait à tous les échanges de
courant du sang et ceux des idées la
France est un Nice une voix de grande
communication entre le nord et le midi
ainsi commence l'histoire de France de
Bainville et comme lui ne pensons
qu'immigration fait partie de la France
et des Français
et depuis toujours
l'immigration est un fait qui fait aussi
la France qui a fait son passé et qui
fera sans doute son avenir
et il ne sert à rien d'être contre
en effet que veut dire être contre le
mouvement des hommes sur la Terre qu'il
fuit pour une partie d'entre eux à cause
de la misère de la persécution ou des
événements climatiques
[Applaudissements]
à quoi cela sert-il d'être contre
lorsque depuis le premier janvier 2022
et quel que soit les gouvernements qui
soient gérés par l'extrême droite ou par
la gauche il y a plus 68% de demande
d'asile en Europe
que signifie en effet d'être contre
l'arrivée de médecins d'infirmiers de
maçon devriez agricoles qui travaillent
dans les vignes par exemple ou des
prêtres
quand la France manque cruellement de
tous ces métiers de toutes ces vocations
cela ne signifie en rien que
la peur de l'altérité ou pire encore le
mensonge démagogique de ceux qui jouent
sur les peurs
non l'immigration n'est pas ce que les
démagogues grandissent
en revanche disons plutôt que
l'immigration est un contrat
un contrat librement consenti par celui
qui souhaite venir en France et le pays
qui veut l'accueillir
et puisque la France entre grand pays
attire grâce à ses valeurs
grâce à son économie
grâce à sa promesse d'avenir
définissons ensemble les exigences
qu'ils ont celles de notre nation pour
accueillir les étrangers
c'est l'ambition du projet de loi que
nous a demandé d'écrire madame la
Première ministre et monsieur le
Président de la République que nous vous
présenterons avec Olivier du soft
d'abord la première exigence de la
France c'est celle de faire respecter
ses règles ses valeurs et son droit
nul ne peut prétendre rester durablement
sur notre sol s'il ne respecte pas la
valeur de la République
comme tous les pays notre relation
demande à être respectée
ici les femmes ont le droit équivalents
aux hommes la liberté sexuelle est
totale la liberté religieuse aussi
que ceux qui commettent des crimes et
des délits prennent conscience qui ne
peuvent pas rester sur le territoire
national car on est comme étant il ne
commettent pas seulement un crime
il commet un crime contre notre propre
accueil
depuis 5 ans 80000 titres de séjour ont
été retirés pour cause d'ordre public ou
de radicalisation
3100 criminels au terroristes ont été
expulsés
mais trop trop de règles spécifiquement
françaises empêche d'expulser avec
criminels sur notre sol
tout en respectant absolument l'article
8 de la Convention de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme nous vous proposerons
dans le texte de loi que nous mettrons à
l'ordre du jour de la semaine nationale
du Sénat de ne plus nous censurer et de
laisser au juge de soin de mesurer si la
vie privée est familiale et le droit au
séjour sont compatibles avec les actes
de graves de vacances qui seront faites
faites aux femmes et aux enfants les
violences sur les policiers les
gendarmes ou les pompiers
faites au nom des crimes du code pénal
ou des trafics de stupéfiants
les propositions législatives que nous
proposerons au nom du ministère de
l'Intérieur seront évidemment proposés
aussi par monsieur le garde des sceaux
pour le volet judiciaire
la fin de la fin de la double peine
c'est en fait pas simplement réclamé par
les Français
elle est aussi et surtout par l'immense
majorité de nos compatriotes étrangers
qui souhaitent ne plus jamais être
confondus avec ceux qui ruinent leur
réputation et leurs efforts parce que
quelques-uns autour de ce comportent mal
il faudrait donc qu'ils en payent le
prix le racisme et la xénophobie
augmente quand l'État se montre peu
capable de châtier des délinquants et
laisse l'amalgame se faire entre tous
les étrangers il faut avoir vécu loin
des quartiers populaires pour ne pas
voir que
malheureusement
l'absence de réponse de la loi fait
aussi monter les extrêmes
deuxième exigence
être étranger sur le sol national c'est
parler la langue du pays
et faire des efforts d'intégration
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
25% des étrangers en situation régulière
parlent très mal ou écrivent très mal le
français
comment voulez-vous bâtir un parcours
mais vous devriez plutôt vous réjouir
des propositions d'intégration du
gouvernement plutôt que plutôt Mesdames
et Messieurs les parlementaires de la
nupesse
comprendre avant la même la fin de la
phrase qu'il s'agit d'une belle
proposition du gouvernement
je vais donc repartir devant ce constat
25% des étrangers en situation régulière
parlent très mal ou écrivent très mal le
français comment voulez-vous bâtir un
parcours de vie professionnelle
personnel et j'allais dire citoyen avec
un tel handicap
l'etame mettra donc les moyens sans
précédent pour améliorer l'intégration
par la langue avec l'augmentation des
heures de français obligatoires
nous augmentons de 25% le budget de
l'intégration pour plus de 100 millions
d'euros dès les trois prochaines années
et nous rapprochons ainsi de nos voisins
comme l'Allemagne et l'Italie qui
exigent un examen désormais de français
pour avoir un titre de séjour long
cette mesure n'existe pas s'il existe un
test il ne conditionne pas le titre de
séjour désormais tout étranger qui
passera un titre qui voudra passer
pardon à titre de séjour long sur le
territoire national devra passer un
examen de français qu'il devra réussir
le ministre du Travail vous évoquera
sans doute le ministre du Travail vous
évoquera sans doute le fait que nous
demanderons au patronat de contribuer
évidemment à cette révolution
linguistique pour que chacune et chacun
se sentent profondément bien dans notre
pays
70 000 étrangers par an seront donc
concernés plus 200 000 étrangers qui
demandent le renouvellement de leur
titre de séjour 270
000 personnes seront donc concernés par
l'examen de français pour cet examen
avec la langue va les principes
en cas de rejet des principes de la
République la loi permettra demain si
vous adoptez ce texte de retirer un
titre de séjour si les étrangers ne
respectent pas les principes de la
République tels que définir la loi
séparatisme
cette notion recouvre l'obligation de
respecter les principes de la République
dont la dignité de la personne humaine
notre laïcité mais aussi notre hymne
national notre drapeau et notre emblème
troisième exigence de la République
celle du travail et de l'intégration par
le travail le ministre du Travail
reviendra ce principe est important ce
principe est même très important et
Soustons une grande partie du projet de
loi il sera détaillé par lui
avec les exigences demandées aux
étrangers la République doit elle
continuer à mieux s'accueillir faire
davantage d'efforts et être plus humain
d'abord à la demande de la première
ministre une réforme profonde de nos
préfectures et de notre façon
d'accueillir les étrangers seront mises
à l'oeuvre en même temps que la loi
adoptée par le Parlement
ainsi il y aura automaticité du
renouvellement des titres de séjour pour
les étrangers déjà sur le sol national
qui n'attendront plus des nièmes rendez
vous des files d'attente numérique et
qui connaîtront parfois de grandes
difficultés pour faire entendre leurs
droits et se trouve parfois irrégulier
par l'incurie de l'organisation même de
l'État
plus de personnes qui contrôleront les
primor arrivant et les personnes qui
doivent partir du territoire national
automaticité pour tous ceux qui ont déjà
un titre de séjour voilà le principe de
la réforme des préfectures qui sera mise
en œuvre par le gouvernement
avec le réforme des préfectures vient la
simplification de notre droit madame la
Première ministre largement évoqué je
voudrais revenir évidemment
sur la réforme du droit d'asile il ne
s'agit pas ici de revoir les pays sûr
les critères pour obtenir l'asile chacun
constatera d'ailleurs que la France en
moyenne donne deux fois moins d'asile
que nos voisins allemands et autant que
nos voisins espagnols et autrichiens
pour un pays qui est plus grand vous
l'avouerez nous ne sommes pas donc
l'axis sur la demande d'asile nous
donnons l'asile à ceux qui le méritent
sur le territoire de la République mais
il faut évidemment
faire une réforme notamment après celle
de l'OFPRA de la CNDA et le garde des
sceaux et moi-même proposeront à la fois
le juge unique tout en laissant la
collégialité pour les arrêts principes à
la demande du Conseil d'État la
territorialisation de la CNDA et la
création d'espace françaises
notre droit doit être plus clair
et rendu plus rapidement
il faut savoir accueillir plus vite ce
qui mérite l'asile il faut évidemment
refuser plus vite ceux qui ne peuvent
pas l'avoir sur notre sol c'est en
prenant trop de temps que nous créons en
situation administrative inextricable
des personnes qui peut être ni
régularisées ni expulsés et qui viennent
ensuite
malheureusement agrandir la corde de
ceux qui sont dans
tous les travaux au noir parfois même la
délinquance que nous faisons ici que
regretter
le droit d'asile refusant
le droit de ainsi refusé vaudra qtf ce
qui voudrait dire une réforme profonde
des voies de recours qui passent en
effet de 12 à 4 et qui empêchera
mécaniquement l'alimentation de flux de
personnes irrégulières sur le territoire
national
enfin son proposition de Monsieur le
garder saut à la suite du drame de
Calais ou 27 migrants ont trouvé la mort
dans la Manche
les dispositions extrêmement fortes sont
adoptées qui alourdiront dans le code
pénal jusqu'à 20 ans de prison le crime
de passeur qui était aujourd'hui qu'un
délit merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
et je crois
et je crois que ici personne ne peut
être complice des passeurs et
malheureusement je crains que vos cris
ne font qu'encourager
ce qui utilise les personnes humaines
comme de la marchandise ou du bétail et
son responsable malheureusement de
toutes ces disparitions et de tous ces
morts
les reconduites aux frontières doivent
être bien évidemment améliorées même si
depuis le 1er janvier de cette année
c'est 21% de plus de reconduites que
compte le gouvernement par la
simplification du droit et par
l'agglomération de numération
diplomatique merci Madame la mise à part
étrangère le texte de loi prévoit
également de spécialiser les centres de
rétention administratif depuis mon
arrivée au ministère de l'Intérieur à la
demande du gouvernement
nous allons centraliser dans l'écran
91% au moment où je parle de personnes
délinquante ou criminel et laisser dans
les assignations résidence les étrangers
régulières qui ne posent pas de problème
d'ordre public aussi le projet de loi
prévoiera l'interdiction de placer des
mineurs de moins de 16 ans dans les
centres de rétention administratif
amélioration de notre reconduite
humanisation de notre accueil des
étrangers fermeté envers ceux qui sont
délinquants intégration pour ceux qui
veulent vivre dans notre belle France le
projet de loi que nous présenterons avec
le ministre du Travail et demande de la
preuve ministre permettra j'en suis sûr
d'améliorer très significativement le
service public rendu à tous nos
concitoyens ne verra pas les étrangers
comme des criminels en puissance ne sera
pas non plus naïf contre ceux qui
veulent atteindre la République
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
de la commission des lois mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les députés à l'entrée de ce
débat le gouvernement porte une
conviction forte le lien entre travail
et intégration pour évident qu'il soit
doit être réaffirmé parce qu'il est la
seule manière d'assurer sa subsistance
parce qu'il est un formidable moyen
d'apprendre la langue et la culture d'un
peuple nous devons réhabiliter le
travail comme vecteur d'intégration et
c'est d'autant plus juste que
l'immigration a toujours permis à la
France de répondre aux besoins de son
économie nous avons besoin des talents
étrangers sans occulter le fait qu'il
nous faut former et accompagner nos
compatriotes cela reste la priorité de
notre politique de l'emploi et la marche
vers le plein emploi va évidemment
s'accompagner d'un recours qui reste
subsidiaire recrutement d'étrangers non
communautaire pour faire face à nos
besoins en compétences et en
qualification
cependant il nous faut aussi regarder
notre système avec lucidité et
considérer que ce système en matière
d'immigration pour le travail et par le
travail est inefficace par plusieurs
aspects et injuste par d'autres d'abord
il est efficace car il ne permet pas à
de nombreux primoires vivants arriver
régulièrement sur notre territoire de se
former et d'être accompagné pour exercer
un emploi sur notre territoire le taux
de chômage des immigrés le montre il est
nettement supérieur à celui des
personnes nées en France ainsi au
premier trimestre 2022 il était d'un peu
plus de 13% contre 7,5% pour l'ensemble
de la population et cet écart entre le
taux de chômage des personnes nées à
l'étranger et le taux de chômage
national moyen est un écart qui est
constant quel que soit les conditions de
l'activité économique en période de
crise comment perdre en période de
croissance
ensuite notre système est aussi
inefficace car il enferme dans
l'illégalité des étrangers présents
depuis longtemps sur notre territoire et
qui travaillent dans des secteurs
d'intention ces personnes qui sont
malheureusement parfois pointées du
doigt dans le cadre du débat que nous
avons ouvert contribue à l'économie
française leur utilité est remarquée et
remarquable elles sont déclarées elles
payent des impôts et leur situation
relève parfois de la traite des êtres
humains pourquoi parce que l'absence de
droit au séjour les rend vulnérables et
précaires des employeurs peu scrupuleux
les oblige à travailler parfois
plusieurs semaines sans repos ou encore
être hébergé dans des conditions
indignes plusieurs décisions de justice
ont mis en exerbes en exergue ça ne vaut
évidemment pas généralisation mais nous
voulons aussi au travers de ce débat et
du texte qui viendra pouvoir condamner
plus sévèrement celles et ceux qui se
livrent ni plus ni moins que de la
traite de la traite d'être humain
ensuite nous voulons progresser parce
que progresser sur ce sujet c'est
progresser sur l'ensemble des conditions
de travail en supprimant ces situations
du pire et en revenant un socle commun
pour l'ensemble des salariés au delà de
celles et ceux qui connaissent
aujourd'hui une situation irrégulière et
sur lesquelles je reviendrai il nous
faut aussi simplifier l'accès au travail
en réexaminant la question les
autorisations préalables exigées pour la
conclusion de chaque contrat de travail
dans le cadre de l'immigration légale et
des cartes de séjour plus réelles dans
les secteurs qui ont largement recours
au contrats cette obligation de demander
une autorisation préalable avant chaque
contrat de travail peut agir en vérité
comme une véritable trappe un travail
dissimulé
j'évoquais leur situation il y a un
instant mais il nous faut donc sortir de
l'absure de l'absurde de jeu perdant
perdants qui concerne la situation
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière
dans des métiers qui manquent réellement
de main d'oeuvre des étrangers présents
depuis plusieurs années sur le
territoire travaillant depuis plusieurs
mois en France dans un métier en tension
sont parfois en situation irrégulière et
sans porte de sortie il travaille
s'intègre sont intégrés et ils demeure
pourtant son droit au séjour ni au
travail la procédure d'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour dites
circulaires Valls est aujourd'hui
appliqué de façon hétérogène sur le
territoire et laisse de surcroît un
grand pouvoir à l'employeur puisque
celui-ci doit soutenir la démarche ce
que ne font pas les plus indélicats
d'entre eux c'est la raison pour
laquelle il nous parais souhaitable que
ces étrangers puissent obtenir un titre
de séjour temporaire pour une année
renouvelable il s'agirait de leur
permettre de travailler dans un métier
en tension de main d'oeuvre il pourrait
ensuite s'insérer dans un parcours plus
classique toujours par le travail et par
la langue ça s'appelle tout simplement
l'intégration et c'est ce que nous
voulons promouvoir comme nous l'avons
indiqué assez récemment avec monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur
nous y travaillons et les concertations
sont en cours mais d'ores et déjà nous
pouvons affirmer qu'il faudra résident
en France depuis plusieurs années pour
baiser bénéficier de ce titre et il
travaillait depuis plusieurs mois il ne
s'agit pas d'un plan de régularisation
massive mais d'une solution donnée à
celle c'est ceux qui sont déjà là qui
travaillent depuis longtemps et qui sont
parfois aussi devenus réguliers en
raison de la complexité des formalités
ou d'accidents de parcours certains
teignes de pensée que nous allons
favoriser le travail des étrangers au
détriment du travail des Français là
aussi c'est un mensonge ou une façon de
faire peur ce type de séjour
s'appliquera à ceux qui travaillent déjà
dans des secteurs en tension des
secteurs où les témoignages
d'entreprises rencontrant des
difficultés de recrutement sont nombreux
c'est d'ailleurs une forte demande de
nombre d'entreprises et non particulier
dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration
c'est aussi dans cet état d'esprit que
nous avons d'ores et déjà initier la
révision de la liste existante des
métiers en tension les textes
prévoyantes qu'elles soient à
intervalles réguliers pour être aussi
adapté que possible cette liste nous
sera utile pour déterminer l'accès au
titre de séjour que je viens d'évoquer
cette liste est déjà utile pour
permettre à des employeurs qui
souhaitent recruter des étrangers non
communautaires de le faire sans
autorisation préalable pour les métiers
de tension c'est l'état du droit la
première ministre l'a rappelé cette
liste n'est plus adaptée les métiers de
la restauration ils sont très peu
présents tout comme ceux de la propreté
elle devra donc être demain mise en
phase avec la réalité car nous
connaissons tous dans cette des secteurs
à la fois les tensions de recrutement
mais aussi la proportion nettement plus
importante que la moyenne de recours à
des travailleurs étrangers
si nous devons regarder la réalité en
face pour ce qui concerne la part des
emplois en tension occupés aujourd'hui
par des travailleurs étrangers en
situation régulière ou irrégulière nous
devons aussi regarder notre réalité en
face c'est la faiblesse ou plutôt la
lenteur des sanctions infligées lorsque
le travail illégal est constaté est
délibéré or c'est une certitude la lutte
contre le travail légal passe par des
sanctions plus facilement plus
facilement applicables il existe
aujourd'hui des sanctions pénales que
nous ne prévoyons pas de modifier elles
sont nécessaires au traitement des
situations les plus graves dès lors que
l'intentionnalité et la dégradation des
conditions de travail sont manifestes il
existe aussi des sanctions
administratives comme la possibilité
pour les préfets de fermer
l'établissement pour une durée maximale
de trois mois il est certainement
opportun de les faciliter il nous faut
aussi une sanction administrative
calibrée pour être plus systématique
comme une amende la sanction n'aurait
pas un caractère automatique mais serait
déployé en fonction de l'appréciation
d'un certain nombre de critères tels que
les ressources et les charges
l'intentionnalité le contexte et la
gravité c'est cela que nous travaillons
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur pour
apporter une réponse rapide
proportionnée efficace à ceux qui ont
recours délibérément intentionnellement
à des travailleurs en situation
irrégulière enfin j'en termine
l'intégration et c'est une évidence au
travail comme ailleurs se fait par la
langue en cohérence avec cette exigence
de maîtrise de la langue nous
considérons que les employeurs doivent
aussi faciliter l'intégration de leur
salarié étrangers par la langue bien
nombreux parmi eux comptent sur la main
d'oeuvre étrangère pour faire tourner
leurs entreprises il n'est donc pas
normal que les employeurs contribuent à
la réussite de l'intégration de leur
salarié par la formation continue par
éventuellement des abonnements à des
comptes personnels de formation ou
encore par le simple fait de libérer du
temps pour pouvoir participer aux
formations à l'apprentissage du français
nous abordons ce sujet de l'immigration
par le travail sans naïveté et surtout
en ne voulant plus et en ne voulant pas
être les complices passifs des
injustices existantes quand on travaille
des étrangers ni naïveté une idéalisme
mais du réalisme et la volonté de
protéger les travailleurs comme les
chefs d'entreprise n'ayant pas d'autres
alternatives
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Elsa faussillon
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine pour une durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
nous aurons donc dans quelques semaines
de longs débat sur l'immigration à la
défaveur d'un nouveau texte que nous
n'avons pas encore le 29e en 40 ans vous
avez monsieur le ministre Darmanin
présenté les premières lignes de ce
texte dans la presse et je dois vous
dire que plus vous en dites à son propos
plus nous craignons que les premières
annonces sur la possible régularisation
de travailleurs sans papier que nous
appelons de nos vœux soirée dites à
portion congrue et ce au profit de
mesures dont le seul appel d'air qu'elle
provoqueront sera celui des idées
d'extrême droite et je dois vous dire
quand vous entendez Jacques Bainville
dans votre intervention c'est plutôt de
mauvaise augure le débat d'aujourd'hui
il s'inscrit dans une période où
l'immigration est devenue un sujet
traité avec une grande irrationalité et
aussi beaucoup d'inhumanité aucun
chiffre n'atteste d'une submersion
migratoire d'ailleurs le sol de
migratoires est stable les grandes
phases de régularisation dans le passé
n'ont suscité aucun appel d'air et les
nombreuses et diverses études réalisées
démontrent combien les migrants
contribuent à la richesse du pays
d'accueil il ne menace ni l'emploi ni
les régimes de protection car ils sont
aussi des producteurs et des
productrices des contribuables des
cotisants et des créateurs et des
créatrices leur régularisation massive
entraînerait une élévation des normes
salariales pas l'inverse c'est peut-être
le problème d'ailleurs
répondre à un défi nécessite donc de
poser d'abord le bon diagnostic nous ne
traversons pas une crise migratoire mais
bien une crise de l'accueil et
particulièrement particulièrement quand
les personnes exilées viennent d'Afrique
du proche ou du Moyen-Orient le
contraste avec l'accueil nécessaire et
solidaire des Ukrainiens nous
interpellent
l'immigration c'est largement le produit
des incursions de pays européens dans
les pays du Sud ce qui migre réagissent
aussi au système mondial des inégalités
dont nous ne pouvons nous exempter tous
les murs dressés n'empêcheront pas ceux
qui n'ont que seul choix le départ de
partir
l'immigration c'est une partie de
l'histoire de notre monde elle est donc
profondément humaine elle exige de nous
de la responsabilité pas de s'envoyer la
balle à qui sera le plus ferme ou qui
sera la plus molle présenter ce sujet
comme un problème grandissant ou impose
ou un trait d'égalité entre immigration
et délinquance est un jeu dangereux qui
participe à légitimer une vision dont
l'histoire est profondément xénophobe
alors je sais il est bien pratique le
discours qui repose sur l'idée du trop
plein d'immigrés tant il permet un récit
alternatif au conséquences de choix
politiques dressés contre le peuple
contre le plus grand nombre alors quand
on s'annonce rempart on ne passe pas les
plats ce discours est dangereux aussi
pour celles et ceux qui arrivent sur
notre territoire comme pour notre
cohésion sociale quand on accorde en
permanence étrangers expulsion
délinquance et parfois même terroriste
terrorisme on met en danger notre
cohésion sociale car cela jette la
suspicion et le rejet
alors il va être beaucoup question d'OK
qtf visiblement c'est le cas d'à peu
près tous les textes sur l'immigration
ces dernières années il y a eu de
nombreuses propositions de multiples
croyez-vous vraiment que la 29ème y
parviendra sachant que l'obstacle majeur
c'est l'absence de laisser passer
conculaire et de titres de voyage non
mais pendant ce temps c'est le silence
autour de celles et ceux qui sont
abandonnés à l'enfer libyen pays
mandatés par l'Europe pour gérer nos
frontières régime qui prend l'argent
d'une main et monnaie des passages
mortels de l'autre silence sur les
refoulements et la corruption ont été
accusés Frontex silence autour du
sauvetage maritime abandonné à des
associations qui sont fondées par des
dons privés ou encore de la gestion de
la coordination des sauvetages qui a été
attribuée à la Libye dans un grand
silence le même qui règne lorsqu'elle
reçoit les appels de détresse en mer
nous ne pouvons pas d'une part dénoncer
la violence et l'instabilité de
certaines régions en crise et dans le
même printemps en nourrir la source
d'une main vendre des armes de l'autre
fléchez l'aide publique au développement
vers le renforcement des frontières
alors nous continuerons de vrai et de
tenter de convaincre que le monde de
demain oblige dès maintenant à préparer
un accueil digne cela passe par une
régularisation de celles et ceux qui
vivent ici qui travaillent ici et vous
le savez qu'il resteront ici et ce avec
un titre de séjour de plein droit la fin
aussi du pouvoir de l'employeur dans la
délivrance du titre de séjour par le
travail cela passe par un accueil digne
en préfecture un accès immédiat à la
protection universelle maladie un
investissement pour l'apprentissage du
français vous nous avez déjà fait le
coup de la fermeté et de l'humanité on
se demande tous les jours où est passé
l'humanité à part au fond de la mer
Méditerranée
la parole est à Monsieur Bertrand
pencher pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire pour
une durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame messieurs les ministres
collègues allons-nous pouvoir nous
engager dans des politiques de migration
efficaces courageuses juste et humaine
allons-nous à l'issue de nos décisions
créer de l'intelligence collective ou
basculer dans la haine et le rejet de
l'autre
constatons d'abord que les crises de par
le monde jettent aujourd'hui de plus en
plus d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants sur
les routes et sur les mers exigeant une
réflexion approfondie et équilibrée sur
l'avenir de nos politiques migratoires
tant au niveau national que européen
leur n'est pas à s'embourbé dans des
postures mortifères de repli sur soi ou
de jouer la facilité ce qui disent ni
politique d'aide au développement pour
les pauvres ni politique d'accueil digne
de ce nom chez nous cela n'a aucun sens
sauf celui de l'inhumanité les migrants
qui tentent de trouver un avenir
meilleur ne le font jamais de gaieté de
cœur il ne quitte jamais leur pays leur
famille leurs racines par pure caprice
ces personnes fuient souvent au risque
de leur vie
territoire ravagé par le réchauffement
climatique une pauvreté galopante des
guerres la répression la france terre
d'accueil pays de la fraternité un atout
a toujours fait partie de cette avenir
meilleur beaucoup d'entre nous
descendons de migrants moi-même
petit-fils de migrants italiens ou mon
grand-père me disait on nous jette des
cailloux on nous crache dessus et ou un
rapport du préfet d'humain disait au
ministre de l'Intérieur ces gens-là ils
sont ils sentent mauvais ils parlent pas
le français ils sont pas intégrables
dans notre société
il n'empêche il n'empêche que nous ne
pouvons pas accueillir tout le monde une
bonne politique de l'immigration c'est
d'abord un meilleur contrôle des
frontières a commencé par celle de
l'Union européenne et le respect de nos
règles et je pense évidemment à Mayotte
qu'il faut traiter séparément il y a
beaucoup à faire dans ce domaine parmi
vos objectifs madame la Première
ministre figure une simplification une
rationalisation du contentieux du droit
des étrangers nous partageons l'objectif
en vous alertant néanmoins sur les
moyens proposés pour y parvenir il n'est
pas question évidemment de réduire les
droits de l'homme les droits
fondamentaux des migrants ainsi l'idée
de généraliser le juge unique de la CNDA
ne nous semble pas aller dans le bon
sens car remettre entre les mains d'une
seule et même personne l'instruction des
recours c'est se priver de nombreux
expertises donc celle du CHR
si nous construisons un accueil plus
digne et plus efficace il nous semble
opportun en contrepartie d'augmenter nos
exigences vis-à-vis des étrangers que
nous accueillons ainsi le renforcement
des capacités d'expulsion de ce
trou-plan gravement l'ordre public et
notamment l'idée de limiter les
protections relatives et quasi absolue
les étrangers dit protégés ça donnant à
des troubles graves nous semblent
raisonnables une bonne politique
d'immigration c'est aussi une bonne
politique d'intégration qui s'est donné
un avenir à ceux qu'elle décide
d'accueillir les simplifications
évoquées pour la future loi nous semble
opportunes en particulier la
simplification de la procédure de
l'autorisation de travail et le
renforcement des dispositifs tels celui
des passeports talents c'est une bonne
idée de créer un nouveau titre de séjour
concernant les métiers sous tension on
en a tant besoin sur le plan du travail
et nous voulons nous aussi des garanties
nous souhaitons que la liste de le
métier prenne réellement en compte les
besoins en fonction des territoires et
ne laisse pas de côté faute de mise à
jour régulières un certain nombre de
travailleurs autre sujet d'inquiétude
qu'adviendra-t-il des personnes qui dans
ce cadre perdront leur emploi c'est
hydro de séjour professionnel étant
particulièrement précaire il faut avoir
l'assurance qu'une perte d'emploi
n'introduira pas une perte du droit au
séjour une politique d'immigration digne
de ce nom c'est celle qui nous
permettrait un retour à l'accès immédiat
également aux soins des demandeurs
d'asile comme avant la mise en place des
trois mois de carence institués en 2019
afin que leur état de santé n'est pas le
temps de se dégrader comme cela arrive
trop souvent aujourd'hui ce qui est
finalement contre-productif y compris
évidemment pour notre système de santé
une politique d'immigration digne de ce
nom c'est aussi celle et ceux qui ne
détournent pas le regard face aux
migrants sans papier qui fois depuis des
années travail de manière non déclarée
sur notre territoire et qui font tout
pour s'intégrer on sait pertinemment
pour des tas de raisons qu'ils ne
pourront jamais être expulsés tout le
monde le sait s'acharner à ne pas leur
donner des papiers c'est les condamnés à
rester au bord de notre société à
basculer dans la pauvreté à dormir dans
nos rues et à verser des larmes de
crocodiles quand nous passons devant des
tentes de migrants qui croupissent dans
des conditions sordides nuitées jour y
compris l'hiver dans les rues de Paris à
ce jeu malsain tout le monde y perd son
âme et sa dignité puisque la plupart
d'entre-travail notre société a besoin
de leurs bras madame la Première
ministre et j'en finis là tout est
question d'équilibre nous resterons
particulièrement vigilants sur la
finalisation de votre projet de loi car
nous souhaitons que ce texte permettent
une politique de l'immigration dans
notre pays enfin efficace parce que
courageuse juste et humaine
la parole est à Madame Aurore berger
pour le groupe renaissance pour une
durée de 15 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame monsieur les membres du
gouvernement monsieur le président de la
commission des lois chers collègues le 9
janvier 2015 lors de la prise d'otages à
l'hypercacher de la Porte de Vincennes à
Paris un jeune travailleur malien
Lassana Betty lit a contribué à sauver
plusieurs Français juifs pris en otage
par un djihadiste par ce geste cet homme
a fait son devoir d'humanité et c'est
toute la République qui lui a rendu
hommage aujourd'hui il a reçu son décret
de naturalisation il est français
le 9 août 2021 un étranger fauche avec
toute l'atrocité des bases instincts le
Père Olivier maire cette fois-ci c'est
le sentiment inverse qui nous accable
comment expliquer qu'un homme entrer
illégalement sur notre sol en 2012
puisque mettre l'irréparable au moment
même où libérer sous contrôle judiciaire
après l'incendie de la cathédrale de
Nantes il n'est lui-même plus expulsable
ces deux exemples nous inspirent au fond
de réactions contraires qui sont les
deux faces d'une même caricature côté
pile il y a ceux qui semblent douter de
tout du haut de leur forteresse qui
ressemblerait plus à une ligne Maginot
l'étranger est présumé délinquant et la
République qui traite dès lors pour de
bons l'humanité l'immigration de e0
n'existe pas et heureusement
côté face il y a ceux qui semblent ne
douter de rien la France serait la
planche de salut du monde moderne fort
heureusement ces projets accueillent
plus qu'il intègrent au point que large
de Noé se dispute souvent au radeau de
la Méduse côté pile c'est donc le verre
à moitié vide de la grandeur de Rome ils
n'ont retenu que le déclin et à leur
phobie et leur phobie tient en deux
apostrophes l'appel d'air côté face
c'est le verre à moitié plein leur
politique commence souvent par accueil
mais finit rarement par expulsion leur
fantasmes c'est un pays all inclusive au
fond la noblesse d'âme des uns répond à
la disposition d'esprit des autres
sans jamais pointer du doigt le paradoxe
que révèle ses files d'attente des
armées numériques plus souterraines
devant les préfectures et les
sous-préfectures pour la délivrance de
titre de séjour le paradoxe donc d'un
système inhumain qui fait subir à des
étrangers en situation régulière le
chemin de croix d'un renouvellement le
paradoxe d'un système inefficace ou la
lourdeur de la politique de guichet
rallonge d'autant plus l'exécution de la
politique d'éloignement après une
probable protestation devant le juge
voyons les choses en face avec lucidité
nos règles européennes et nationales
sont devenus inadaptées nos procédures
sont longues les voies de recours sont
multiples en parallèle nous vous avons
un système d'aide monétaire social
médical bien plus élaborée que tous nos
voisins ce système est donc doublement
inefficace d'abord car toute personne de
mauvaise foi qui demande un titre de
séjour dans notre pays dispose d'une
latitude d'action pour s'enfermer dans
une manœuvre dilatoire et détourner le
système à son avantage ensuite car toute
personne vertueuse sans intention
d'essouffler le système peut se perdre
dans le maquis de notre enfer procédural
il faut donc remettre à plat notre droit
et garantir ce faisant celui des
étrangers le simple acronyme occuté F a
acquis à lui seul la postérité des
édifices à abattre c'est devenu le
symbole de l'inefficacité de nos
politiques migratoires peu importe que
la part des immigrés dans la population
soit stable le taux d'exécution des
aquittf est égrené chaque jour disséquer
sans que l'on sache très bien à quoi il
correspond et les obstacles auxquels
nous nous confrontons ces obstacles les
voici c'est d'abord le règlement
européen de Dublin en vertu duquel est
rendu responsable du traitement d'une
demande d'asile le premier État où
arrive le demandeur le mécanisme est
élémentaire mais ça déclinaison est
aujourd'hui inopérante
les Etats frontaliers Crolles sous les
arrivées et peine enregistrer la masse
des demandes c'est le cas de la Grèce
d'autres États détournent volontairement
le système en incitant les migrants à
traverser leur pays sans les enregistrer
c'est le cas de la Hongrie le nouveau
pacte suggéré par la Commission
européenne trace une ligne cohérente
faire en sorte d'une part que les
demandes d'asile déboutés ne puisse plus
bénéficier dans aucun autre pays de
l'union d'une allocation et d'un droit à
l'hébergement prévoir d'autre part que
les pays qui se refusent à accueillir
les migrants finance en contrepartie les
retours forcés le second obstacle c'est
notre procédure administrative pour
traiter les 271 milles primo délivrance
en 2021 dans un délai raisonnable soit
on augmente les moyens ce que nous
faisons souvent sans votre soutien soit
on change les procédures ce que nous
allons faire
la pratique d'instruction doit être
simplifiée certains étrangers présentent
plusieurs demandes de titres de séjour à
la suite en s'appuyant sur un fondement
puis sur un autre ce qui embolise le
système et alimente le contentieux le
dévoiement du droit d'asile participe
notamment de ce fait le troisième
obstacle c'est notre procédure
juridictionnelle l'embolie menace la
justice 40% de l'activité des tribunaux
administratifs et quasiment 50% des
cours administratifs d'appel c'est du
contentieux des étrangers et encore la
plupart du temps ce n'est pas un litige
à trancher avec l'administration mais
une voie détournée pour faire traiter sa
demande dans un délai raisonnable et
même sur les litiges en eux-mêmes le
procédure allait la règle la lisibilité
devient l'exception au point qu'une qtf
peut être soumise selon qu'un délai de
départ volontaire est ou non accordé et
selon le fondement duquel elle est
adoptée à un délai de recours de 48
heures de 15 jours ou d'un mois
il faut donc remettre à plat le système
en l'état il n'existe pas moins de 12
procédures contentieuses qui se
recoupent partiellement le Conseil
d'État en suggère 3 enfin notre
politique d'éloignement constitue un
ultime obstacle réduire le temps
administratif puis le temps
juridictionnel ne sert à rien si notre
taux d'exécution des mesures
d'éloignement reste faible or ce taux
d'exécution c'est continuellement
détérioré c'est l'effet ciseaux de la
politique d'éloignement d'un côté les
mesures prononcées augmentent de l'autre
leur taux d'exécution chute et pour
cause la chaîne d'éloignement manque de
synergie il faut identifier les
personnes en situation irrégulière qui
organisent leur fuite d'identité le pays
destinataires doit ensuite les
reconnaître comme ressortissants avec un
laissez-passer consulaire ce qui est
impossible vous en conviendrez dans un
certain nombre de pays prenez
l'Afghanistan ce n'est pas tout le
dispositif de rétention administratif
étant saturation et la procédure
d'éloignement ce judiciarise invalidant
parfois l'arrêté d'expulsion
une partie de la solution est donc
nationale pour interpeller pour
augmenter la possibilité de placement en
rétention une autre est européenne pour
avoir une stratégie globale et sortir de
l'impasse avec les pays tiers non
coopératifs mais ce que les Français ne
comprennent plus ce qui crée frustration
exaspération c'est la trappe à
illégalité c'est-à-dire ce trou dans la
raquette qui organise le phénomène des
nids ces étrangers qui ne sont ni
expulsables ni régularisables ni
expulsable d'abord parce qu'ils sont
entrés en France avant l'âge de 13 ans
ou résine depuis plus de 10 ans où son
mari a un conjoint français depuis plus
de 3 ans bref des verrous législatives
qui font obstacle à leur expulsion mais
ni régularisable ensuite car s'il pousse
l'incivilité jusqu'à l'air délinquance
on ne peut pas leur délivrer les titres
de séjour dans un second temps ce que
les Français ne comprennent pas ce sont
les paradoxes sur l'immigration du
travail parmi les travailleurs étrangers
qui conduisent nos VTC ou oeuvres en
cuisine dans nos restaurants nombreux
sont dans l'illégalité faut de titres de
séjour parfois cette trappe à illégalité
fait la courte échelle à la délinquance
mais pouvons-nous sincèrement faire
tourner nos commerces nos usines et nos
restaurants sans eux la réponse est non
ce n'est pas moi qui vous le dis ce sont
les chefs d'entreprise qui nous
interpellent ils appellent à une
régularisation des travailleurs il
plébiscite le nouveau titre de séjour
renouvelables pour les métiers en
tension annoncé par le gouvernement
voilà une réponse concrète à
l'intégration il faut faciliter les
démarches des étrangers sécurisés les
compétences des entreprises ce n'est pas
normal qu'un étranger qui est une force
vive de la nation depuis plusieurs
années qui s'intègrent par l'effort et
par le travail qui s'acquitte d'un loyer
qui épouse nos valeurs plonge dans
l'illégalité du jour au lendemain sans
que l'on comprenne pourquoi son titre
est suspendu c'est le cas de ce chef
d'entreprise de maçonnerie en
Eure-et-Loir frappé par la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre qui ne peut pas garder un
jeune travailleur originaire du Sierra
Leone auquel a été notifié une mesure
d'expulsion malgré un parcours
exemplaire
il y a également la nécessité d'aspirer
des compétences et des talents à forte
valeur ajoutée c'est à dire choisir
notre immigration il nous faut permettre
l'implantation des médecins non
communautaire en facilitant de façon
dérogatoire les procédures
administratives pour leur venue et en
s'assurant que le nouveau dispositif de
reconnaissance des praticiens diplômés
hors de l'Union européenne soit bel et
bien effectivement tout en ayant
conscience que tout ceci n'est pas un
jeu à somme nul le Maghreb qui fournit
notre plus gros contingent de médecin
étrangers combinent ainsi indirectement
nos déserts médicaux en agrandissant les
siens
une fois ce que je viens de dire une
fois ces constaté quelle valeur
portons-nous et quelle lucidité devant
nous avoir en matière d'immigration ne
compte pas moins de 21 lois en 32 ans
j'ai relu les discours des différents
ministres de l'Intérieur qui se sont
succédés à cette tribune les mêmes mots
souvent été employés les mêmes promesses
sous en formulées avec toujours ce
mouvement de balancier entre l'expulsion
et l'intégration en lui ont rarement
l'un et l'autre on embrassant d'un seul
regard les deux statues qui derrière moi
et face à vous se dressent de part et
d'autre de la tapisserie des Gobelins à
gauche la liberté à droite l'ordre
public la question n'est pas tant la
recherche d'un équilibre dont personne
ne fixerait en vérité les curseurs au
même niveau mais d'assumer le en même
temps c'est à dire une radicalité et
dans la liberté de l'accueil et dans
l'ordre public à la reprise du contrôle
notre enjeu
notre enjeu mes chers collègues n'est
pas de cocher une nouvelle case avec
cette loi c'est de partir du réel pour
garantir une véritable politique
publique dont les effets perceptibles
par tous redonne aux Français le
sentiment que nous sommes maître de
notre destin que nous sommes une nation
souveraine n'oublions jamais qu'une
France qui accueille c'est d'abord une
république qui intègre un état qui
protège c'est aussi un pouvoir souverain
qui sait éloigné pas de grandeur sans
ouverture pas d'ouverture sans
responsabilité il nous faut lutter
contre le sentiment d'impuissance
refuser aussi bien les totems que l'État
vous c'est bien là le cœur de ce que
doit être notre travail parlementaire
assumons ici d'être une nation qui s'est
nourrit de l'immigration les immigrés
ont été nos frères d'armes je pense au
183000 Tirailleurs Africains que gardera
à jamais en mémoire la boue des
tranchées la libération de la Corse en
1943 grâce à l'assaut des Tamor marocain
on concourt des soldats d'Afrique dans
l'enfoncement de la ligne Siegfried en
autant qu'ils ont été et sont nos
travailleurs assumons de réguler de
maîtriser les flux pour mieux intégrer
assumons d'affronter le défi de cette
intégration avec des populations
culturellement plus éloignées et posant
des défis nouveaux sans jamais quitter
de vues que nous sommes une création
continue de l'histoire pas juste une
somme de communauté juxtaposées une
politique utile pour la France et claire
pour les Français et celles qui
s’ancrent dans notre histoire et la
respectent et entend les doutes et les
inquiétudes légitimes des Français
assumons de protéger des Français
solidaires mais qui craignent aussi le
déclassement le dumping social tout
autant que les immigrés qui risquent la
traite humaine assumons de pointer
l'exploitation quand elle frappe à nos
portes la quintessence étant les Dark
kitchen et ses livraisons à domicile sur
lesquelles il nous faudra légiférer
car ce que les Français ne comprennent
plus se sont enfin vos contradictions
allons-nous devoir expulser tous les
étrangers de France ce dont le patronyme
sonne moins hexagonales est-ce rendre
grâce aux 20% de médecins qui ont sauvé
des vies pendant le covid est-ce rendre
service au réfugiés et qui fuit la
guerre
en quoi greffer des compétences
hautement qualifiées sur des métiers en
tension qui font la richesse de notre
pays crairait-il un quelconque appel
d'air pourquoi ne pas renouveler
automatiquement les titres pluriannuels
de ceux qui ne posent aucun problème et
qui n'ont aucun casier judiciaire comme
si la file d'attente était une partie du
contrat d'intégration républicaine
pourquoi enfin ne pas concentrer nos
moyens sur les primo arrivants les
personnes sous occupées F et celles qui
ont un casier judiciaire au fond l'enjeu
pour notre majorité n'est d'être jugé ni
par Marine Le Pen ni par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il y a qu'un juge de paix les
Français le pacte social que nous leur
présentons
la clarté des propositions que nous leur
formulons l'efficacité des politiques
publiques que nous portons nul ne pourra
s'étonner de voir l'abstention galoper
si le cœur de notre politique régalienne
le coeur de l'expression de notre
souveraineté alors nous sommes mis en
échec face au risque de l'impuissance
nous devons répondre par la clairvoyance
face au risque et du populisme tout
autant que de la démagogie nous devons
répondre par la lucidité et c'est ce à
quoi nous nous employons je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Marine Le Pen
pour le groupe rassemblement national
pour une durée de 10 minutes
merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre
mes chers collègues ce débat sur
l'immigration qui vient ouvrir une
séquence législate législative puisque
le gouvernement a annoncé un texte à la
rentrée et pour nous un débat
fondamental parce qu'il porte sur l'un
des phénomènes majeurs de la seconde
moitié du XXe siècle appelée à
s'aggraver encore dans les décennies
d'instabilité à venir
pour les personnalités politiques qui
savent s'extraire des polémiques
subalternes qui sont capables de voir
loin et haut qui portent en elle
l'intérêt national la question de
l'immigration est centrale le phénomène
de l'émigration personne ne peut en
mésestimer l'aspect humain les tragédies
les souffrances que l'arrachement à une
terre ancestrale à sa culture aussi
induit nous sommes bien placés avec
l'échec de l'assimilation et même de
l'intégration pour connaître les
contraintes et les exigences car
réenracinement dans un nouveau pays
peuvent engendrer pour les hommes d'État
comme demain pour les historiens
l'immigration soulève plus largement la
question des grands flux démographiques
qui doivent impérativement sous peine de
crise de tension ou de drames être
régulé par les États souverains
l'histoire du monde tient souvent en une
donnée la démographie
la prospérité des pays comme les
équilibres du monde l'harmonie des
sociétés comme la pérennité des
ressources planétaires en dépendent la
seule Afrique passera entre 1950 et 2100
de 227 millions d'habitants à 4,5
milliards pour ces pays c'est un défi
considérable pour les nôtres c'est un
défi encore plus grand parce que
l'immigration anarchique et massive
signifie la fin de nos équilibres
sociaux une atteinte à
l'harmoniculturelle de nos pays la
contestation de nos valeurs et parfois
nous ne liberté et à la fin un risque
pour la sécurité et même la paix civile
situation dramatique que connaît
aujourd'hui Mayotte
tous les voyants sont au rouge des
quartiers entiers des villes voir des
départements comme la Seine-Saint-Denis
sont en passe de devenir des zones
étrangères un ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur
fondateur du mouvement présidentiel vous
a averti à deux reprises mais vous
n'écoutez même plus les paroles de bon
sens et de courage qui émanent désormais
de vos propres rangs avec une vision
quasi coloniale vous continuez à vouloir
que les problèmes de l'Afrique se règle
en Occident en brandissant une veine
culpabilisation de nos sociétés vous
nous expliquez que nos pays seraient
tenus d'accueillir les populations du
monde victimes d'insécurité économique
climatiques ou politiques pourquoi des
populations de culture moyen-orientales
devraient-elles être accueillie à
Saint-Lys ou à kayak et pas dans les
monarchies pétrolières cousines dont les
richesses par habitant atteignent des
niveaux indécents
pourquoi ne pas admettre car réfugié aux
révocations à rentrer chez lui une fois
la crise dans son pays passée pourquoi
ne pas reconnaître le scandaleux
dévoiement du droit d'asile que nous
subissons depuis 30 ans ça fait 5 ans
que vous êtes de pouvoir 5 ans que
l'action publique en matière de contrôle
de l'immigration s'affaisse comment
témoigne l'effondrement de l'exécution
des occupés F le piteux cafouillage de
la gestion des migrants de l'Océane
Viking ou le chaos migratoire à Paris il
est vrai que déjà en 2015 le ministre
Emmanuel Macron déclarait que les
réfugiés constitués une opportunité
économique et appelait à ne pas
gouverner au sondage et tant pis pour le
peuple français qui paye dans ses rues
ses écoles ses hôpitaux et ses prisons
le prix de votre incurie
la réalité c'est qu'aucun pays n'a
montré autant de générosité que la
France depuis 40 ans elle s'y est même
ruinée elle n'en a plus les moyens alors
que partout les services publics sont
exemples nous n'avons plus rien à
partager que des difficultés économiques
et sociales que des problèmes
sécuritaires et des menaces
d'embrassement nous sommes entrés sous
la présidence d'Emmanuel Macron dans des
logiques de pénurie de restriction de
rationnement de rupture énergétique en
bref de tiers mondialisation accélérée
comment peut-on dans ce malheureux état
prétendre jouer les généreux donateurs
ou les sauveurs du monde
la question de l'immigration est un
océan de mensonges de manipulation de
non-dit et de culpabilisation permanente
mensonge et manipulations quand après
nous avons expliqué faussement que
l'immigration était arrêtée depuis 1974
les campagnes de propagande d'État ont
profé qu'elle était une chance pour la
France aujourd'hui tout est fait pour
l'invisibiliser pour faire croire
qu'elle n'existerait pas ou pire qu'elle
serait inéluctable non dit et
culpabilisation quand les pouvoirs
publics s'ingénient à manipuler le
nombre de clandestins en recourant à des
régularisations incessantes celui des
étrangers par des naturalisations
massives agnez le poids écrasant de
l'immigration dans l'explosion de
l'insécurité
dans le même temps on refuse d'évaluer
le nombre d'illégaux présents sur le
territoire on refuse d'estimer l'impact
social de l'immigration ou en déterminer
le coût total la vérité c'est que les
immigrationnistes sont conscients que
les peuples attachés à leur culture et à
leur mode de vie ces peuples qui ont
encore un instinct de vie ou de survie
qui ont combattu durant des siècles pour
leur liberté et leur valeur ne veulent
pas de cette submersion
pour les dirigeants français ou
européens
habité par une vision globaliste qui
chaque jour se fracasse sur la
recomposition du monde l'immigration
n'est pas un problème mais un projet un
projet qu'il faut imposer au peuple par
le mensonge par parfois par l'omission
par la manipulation et par la politique
du fait accompli permettez-moi une
confidence je préfère encore des
immigrationnistes assumées comme nos
collègues de la France insoumise et leur
projet faussement humaniste mais sans
équivoque de créolisation aux
immigrationnistes honteux qui peuplent
la vie politique depuis 40 ans c'est
partisans
du laisser aller et du laisser passer
qui s'abrite derrière des discours
prétendument ferme pour laisser se
poursuivre en Souma la submersion de nos
pays qui s'abrite derrière des motifs
pseudo-humanitaires pour laisser se
dérouler devant nos yeux un gigantesque
trafic d'être humain vous l'avez compris
et compris depuis longtemps ceci n'est
pas notre projet nous croyons aux
nations et au peuple nous croyons que
les hommes sont des êtres qui se
définissent par des filiation et des
affiliations des allégeances et des
interdépendances des histoires
personnelles et collectives qui font
deux des êtres d'affection familiale
d'appartenance culturelle d'attachement
national
ils ne sont pas comme vous le professeur
des aniware selon la formule de David
good art des nomades destinées à errer
dans un monde indifférencié des
créatures interchangeables ils ne
peuvent résumer leur vie à des actes
reproduction et de consommation il n'est
de pire faute morale que de déraciner
quelqu'un de le priver de son histoire
de sa mémoire ou de sa terre c'est
pourquoi nous pensons que l'immigration
est la dernière des solutions cela
signifie que le monde est pas seulement
l'Europe doit s'engager dans une
politique d'aide au développement des
pays pauvres une aide au développement
qui profite réellement à leurs habitants
et non à leur dirigeants corrompus cela
signifie que la question des réfugiés
doit être traitée régionalement dans le
cadre de cité azilia des cités d'accueil
installés autour des zones en crise nous
devons cesser d'admettre ces
détournements du droit d'asile qui en
ruine la pertinence juridique et parce
que le message doit être celui de la
fermeté les régularisations doivent être
prohibées le droit de vivre selon nos
lois et nos coutumes selon nos rites et
nos modes de vie que nous reconnaissons
au peuple du monde nous le revendiquons
pour nous
tout comme nous revendiquons le droit à
la continuité historique le droit de
vivre conformément à nos valeurs de
civilisation conformément à notre
conception de la vie et de l'homme c'est
pourquoi nous réclamons une grande loi
de régulation de l'immigration à l'image
de ce qui se fait au Danemark d'après
les premiers éléments que nous avons il
apparaît que nous ne te retrouverons
rien de cela dans votre projet futur
projet de loi c'est un énième texte
placebo qui n'a pour objet que de tenter
de faire croire aux citoyens distraits
que vous agissez alors que la situation
migratoire est plus que jamais hors de
contrôle un texte qui loin de réguler le
flux migratoire ouvre avec le prétexte
des métiers en tension de nouvelles
voies d'entrée frauduleuses ou des
régularisations massives tout cela se
faisant à la demande d'un patrona sans
scrupule toujours avec le même argument
les Français seraient un peuple de
feignants et de réfractaires alors que
c'est votre immigrationnisme qui porte
en lui-même le déclassement les salaires
bas et l'affaissement dramatique de la
productivité des emplois
nous nous refusons de voir ainsi le
trafic des hommes légalisés nous
refusons de voir d'autres pays submergé
quand dans le même tentant de jeunes
Français se sent obligés de quitter
notre pays les Français sont très
majoritaires à penser que l'immigration
doit cesser ils sont également très
majoritaires à penser que ce
gouvernement est incapable de juguler ce
fléau j'ai proposé durant la dernière
campagne présidentielle un projet de
référendum sur cette question il est
urgent nécessaire et surtout
démocratique que le peuple français
puisse enfin se prononcer sur cette
question fondamentale
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Mathilde panot
pour le groupe la France insoumise pour
une durée de 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre collègue
s'il est un sujet qui fait la part belle
aux effets de manche coup de menton
gesticulation exagérée bombage de torse
vin en phase inutile fantasme variés
c'est sans aucun doute celui de la
politique de l'immigration depuis 40 ans
ce sujet obéit un régime de parole
particuliers la production de signes il
faut afficher fermeté dureté si bien que
vous êtes moins intéressé par ce que
vous dites que par les faits supposé sur
votre auditoire depuis 40 ans la
fonction sociale de ce sujet est
exclusivement son instrumentalisation à
des fins politiques chacun y trouve son
compte Marine Le Pen à l'instant
sautille de joie à l'idée d'aborder
l'unique marqueur de sa petite boutique
de haine les LR raffolent de la
politique de l'immigration envisagé
comme le seul espace qu'il leur reste
pour se différencier de vous et
collectivement nous fournissons le décor
de votre entreprise de séduction de la
droite votre grille de lecture étriqué
du sujet guidé par la démagogie et celle
imaginaire entre un prétendu angélisme
et l'inhumanité la plus classe pourtant
une autre voix est possible nous sommes
venus vous dire de revenir à la raison
29 lois 29 lois depuis 1980 le
soi-disant tabou de l'immigration est en
réalité brisée au rythme d'une loi tous
les deux ans
pourquoi pourquoi ne jamais tirer de
bilan comment expliquer qu'un
gouvernement prétendument efficace
doivent s'y reprendre plus d'une fois
pour régler ce qu'il présente comme un
problème à moins de supposer que c'est
loin finalement peut avoir avec l'objet
qu'elle traite il ne s'agit pas de faire
mais de montrer que l'on fait en matière
d'immigration mieux vaut une
démonstration de force une politique du
chiffre qu'une politique raisonnée la
temporalité n'est d'ailleurs jamais
innocente il y a toujours une raison
pour semer le poison de la discorde dans
le pays collègue les bonnes décisions
sont celles prises de sang-froid sur ce
sujet en particulier sont entretenus
sciemment les angoisses qui tétanisent
la réflexion avant toute chose il faut
faire acte de sa lubrité publique loin
des fantasmes d'une submersion
migratoire la France est l'un des pays
d'Europe de l'Ouest où l'immigration est
parmi les plus faible la plupart des
migrations se fait en réalité entre les
pays du Sud
contrairement à vos élucubrations
xénophobes personne ne Roger ne compare
les régimes sociaux européens avant de
venir en France comme le font en
revanche vos milliardaires lorsqu'ils
hésitent entre la Suisse et les îles
Fidji pour choisir le régime fiscal le
plus avantageux
l'aide médicale d'État sur lequel vous
êtes si prolixe ne représente que 0,5 %
des dépenses de santé prise en charge
par l'Assurance Maladie les personnes
immigrées rencontrent surtout un
problème de non recours à ce droit et un
important renoncement aux soins
collègues revenait donc à la raison les
déplacements de population sont une
réalité historique vous ne construirez
jamais de Mûrs assez grand pour vous
protéger de l'aspiration de chaque être
humain à une vie meilleure
il faut donc permettre à chacun de vivre
dignement là où il est mais cela exige
de faire cesser une certaine hypocrisie
car ceux qui stigmatisent les immigrés
sont les mêmes qui soutiennent les
politiques libérales dévastatrices pour
les pays du Sud les mêmes qui promènent
des accords de libre-échange quand ce ne
sont pas des guerres le capitalisme néo
libéral n'a d'autres vocations que
d'épuiser les ressources et les êtres
humains et de rendre le monde
fondamentalement inhabitable
oui collègues votre hypocrisie vous fait
trébucher d'une bêtise à l'autre vous
êtes des hypocrites quand vous tolérez
sans mal la législation sur les
travailleurs détachés mettant en
concurrence des travailleurs européens
dans une course effrénée vers le moins
disant social hypocrite quand vous
serrez la vis des politiques
d'immigration rendant la vie de
centaines de milliers de gens
impossibles pourtant bienheureux quand
les mêmes contribuent à tenir notre pays
debout pendant la crise sanitaire
hypocrite quand vous parlez sans cesse
de la valeur travail comme d'un facteur
d’intégration et refusé que les
demandeurs d'asile exerce un emploi
pendant le délai d'examen de leur
dossier hypocrites quand l'État lui-même
fabrique des sans-papiers par une
dématérialisation inhumaine pas de
rendez-vous en préfecture pas de
renouvellement de titre pas de
renouvellement plein d'emploi et parfois
plus de logements hypocrite car vous
entretenez la délocalisation sur place
des secteurs entiers de l'économie du
BTP à la restauration en passant par les
services à la personne repose sur cette
main d'oeuvre bon marché condamné à la
SERV par la menace qui pèse constamment
sur leur tête l'expulsion hypocrisie
ultime lorsqu'en plus de fabriquer des
personnes sans papiers vous les
exploitez je salue les travailleurs
sous-traitants de la Poste présent ici
en tribune depuis un an ils tiennent
trois piquets de grève devant Chronopost
à Alfortville des à
Coudray-Montceaux et encore récemment
devant RSI à Gennevilliers vous savez
que la Poste entreprise à capital public
emploie des personnes sans papiers
corvéables à merci temps partiel imposé
par des salaires de misère embauche à
trois ou quatre heures du matin pas de
paiement d'heure supplémentaire pas
d'arrêt maladie ni de pause
réglementaires vous le savez
qu'avez-vous à leur dire
vous préférez laisser l'impunité
patronale perdurer
hypocrite enfin quand certains parlent
ici de retourner en Afrique et font
travailler des personnes sans papiers
dans leur vigne comme Monsieur de
Fournas
ayez au moins les atouts de la cohérence
mettez un terme au régime des
travailleurs détachés et régulariser
tous les travailleurs sans papiers
collègues l'immigration est un phénomène
qui connaîtra des changements d'échelle
les conséquences du dérèglement
climatique conduiront un milliard de
personnes sur les routes de l'exil
d'anciens circonstances il nous faut
choisir le chaos ou l'entraide dès
aujourd'hui l'urgence climatique exige
qu'une aide financière et matérielle à
la bifurcation écologique soit attribuée
au pays les plus vulnérables fondés sur
les transferts de savoir et par la
reconnaissance d'un statut de détresse
environnementale la seule réponse
raisonnable et d'organiser la solidarité
en vue du plus grand défi que l'humanité
aura à connaître il nous faut donc de
réelles politiques publiques pour
organiser l'accueil pour cela la
philosophie Emma en partage depuis des
siècles un principe qui nous est
précieux agir de telle sorte que la
maxime de notre action puisse être
érigée en loi universelle personne
collègue ni responsable de sa naissance
dans la misère dans un pays pauvre en
guerre ou un pays en première ligne face
aux dérèglement climatiques
ayez donc le courage de traiter ces
personnes avec dignité renforcer les
structures d'accueil d'hébergement dites
à Monsieur Darmanin de cesser la
criminalisation outrancière des
associations qui donnent juste à
beauhari à manger aux exilés à Calais
abolissez la femme délit de solidarité
mettez un terme à l'enfermement des
enfants dans les centres de rétention
interdisaient enfin les tests osseux
cesser pour finir votre chasse sur les
terres de l'extrême droite alors nous
parlons 342 jeunes dorment devant le
Conseil d'État après avoir passé 6 mois
à la rue ils veulent aller à l'école
mais Monsieur le Ministre Darmanin est
trop occupé à montrer les muscles les
politiques d'immigration ne peuvent
pourtant être réduites au Giron
sécuritaire elles doivent inclure la
santé l'éducation la culture la lutte
contre les dixcriminations et être
articulé sur le long terme et avant
toute chose madame la Première ministre
il faut que tout le monde dans ce pays
puisse vivre dignement lorsque vous
détruisez les services publics ce sont
les personne les plus pauvres que Vous
sanctionnez en priorité et parmi elles
les derniers arrivés en France vous ne
parviendrez pas à faire diversion en ce
qui concerne les conditions matérielles
d'existence du peuple la colère qui
gronde ne sera jamais dissipée avec des
lois pointant des boucs émissaires vous
voulez rétablir l'ordre abandonnez votre
réforme des retraites bloquez les prix
augmenter les salaires et partager les
richesses
pour le reste collègue
la France a pour promesse liberté
égalité fraternité chacun un peu en
faire le serment c'est le propre d'une
nation universaliste
j'achève avec ces mots
nous sommes dans l'eau aidez-nous s'il
vous plaît nous sommes en train de
mourir nous sommes dans la mer dedans il
fait froid
ce sont les derniers mots prononcés par
l'une des 27 personnes exilées mortes
dans une traversée de la Manche en 2021
parmi elles une petite fille de 7 ans
il leur a été répandu oui mais vous êtes
dans les eaux anglaises collègues
j'alertent il serait erroné de ne voir
dans cette réponse qu'une faute
individuelle sans percevoir la longue
entreprise collective de
déshuminalisation raciste qui l'a rendu
possible tant de paroles ont alimenté
ces dernières années ce processus au
terme duquel certaines vies ne valent
pas la peine d'être sauvées et
certainement d'être pleurer cette
tragédie est l'aboutissement de
politique dans le paradigme est toujours
la sévérité contre tout soupçon de
laxisme nous savons au fond quel est le
point culminant de cette rhétorique
mortifère le laisser mourir en mer
encore une fois il faut revenir à la
raison
l'humanisme n'est pas une opinion
politique elle est une exigence morale
qui s'impose à tous
ceux que la mort des autres ne foudroie
plus ces cartes de notre commune
humanité
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre-Henri
Dumont pour le groupe les républicains
pour une durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues fiasco
faillite des bandas d'échecs les mots
pour décrire les résultats de la
stratégie migratoire menée depuis 5 ans
par le Président de la République et ses
affidés successifs ne manquent pas
contrairement à votre courage politique
qui lui fait gravement défaut record
historique de titre de séjour délivrés
record historiques de demande de
demandeurs d'asile record historique
d'inexécution d'obligation de quitter le
territoire français record historique de
clandestin record historique du coût de
l'aide médicale d'État record historique
d'étrangers en prison vous avez madame
la Première ministre réussi le Grand
Chelem de l'inertie administrative de
l'incurie migratoire et de l'abandon de
la France
et ce représentant une menace pour
l'ordre public alors que votre ministre
de l'intérieur était favorable à la
double peine l'acheter quand le problème
de recrutement de certains secteurs vous
ne trouvez comme seule réponse que la
régularisation massive de clandestinée
quand vous refusez de supprimer les
visas à l'aide publique au développement
et les transferts d'argent vers les pays
qui refusent de reprendre leur
ressortissant illégalement présent sur
notre territoire lâcheté quand vous
refusez de restreindre l'aide médicale
d'État au sol qu'aggrave l'acheter quand
vous ne voyez l'immigration que sous le
seul prisme de l'asile vous avez une
occasion unique peut-être même la
dernière de reprendre la main sur la
politique migratoire de notre pays pour
cela il vous faudra du courage puisque
vous en êtes dépourvu nous députés les
républicains sommes prêts en avoir pour
vous pour peu que vous écoutiez de
propositions ce que vous faites toujours
avec 5 ans de retard nous vous le disons
cependant clairement
si vous maintenez votre volonté de
régulariser massivement les clandestins
nous voterons contre l'ensemble de votre
futur projet de loi qu'importe ce qu'il
contient d'autres dans cette disposition
crée un appel d'air et constitue une
prime à l'illégalité au Royaume-Uni sous
couvert du même prisme de réalisme
économique Boris Johnson avait promis en
2019 la régularisation de 500000
clandestins depuis jamais il n'y a eu
autant de malheureux qui tentent leur
chance au large de ma circonscription au
péril de leur vie sur des rafaux de
fortune encouragés par cet exemple
exploité par des réseaux de passeurs
madame la Première ministre chaque année
400 000 étrangers entre légalement dans
notre pays ce chiffre est en
augmentation d'un tiers en disant si
c'est 400 000 étrangers formaient une
ville elle serait la cinquième plus
peuplée de France nous demandons à
réduire drastiquement ce nombre car nous
sommes dans la capacité de bien intégrer
tous ces étrangers une bonne politique
migratoire doit d'abord définir le
nombre maximum que notre pays peut
intégrer en fonction du nombre de
logements disponibles du nombre
d'emplois du nombre de professeurs pas
l'inverse
deux chiffres c'est au Parlement dans
décidé c'est là la seule solution pour
passer d'une immigration familiale sous
qualifiée subit à une immigration de
travail sur qualifiée choisie seul 13%
des premiers titres de séjour sont
délivrés pour motifs économiques alors
que ce chiffre est de 33% partout
ailleurs par votre lâcheté la France et
le seul pays de l'OCDE ou l'immigration
un impact négatif sur les finances
publiques en France l'immigration n'est
pas une chance elle est une charge
40% des immigrés ont un niveau scolaire
inférieur ou égal au brevet des collèges
c'est le double du reste de la
population créant des trappes à bas
salaire dans les métiers et les moins
qualifiés sur les 280 000 titres
objectifs de ces jours délivrés 90 000
leçons pour motif familial qu'avez-vous
prévu pour réduire ce chiffre
qu'avez-vous prévu pour proposer
d'arrêter l'octroyer automatiquement les
titres de séjour aux époux étrangers de
Français qui ne parlent pas un mot de
notre langue qui n'en respecte ni les
lois ni les coutumes êtes-vous prêt à
réduire drastiquement le regroupement
familial comme le Canada
l'actualité nous le démontre
tragiquement la principale voie d'entrée
de l'immigration illégale c'est
l'immigration légale c'est à dire des
étrangers qui se maintiennent
irrégulièrement en France à l'expiration
du titre de séjour vous ne risquerez pas
réduire le nombre de clandestins si vous
ne réduisez pas le nombre de titres de
ces jours délivrés l'étranger le plus
facile à expulser c'est celui qui ne
rentre pas il faut donc pour cela
réduire le nombre de types de séjour
délivrés pour les étudiants en
particulier dans les filières qui ne
forment pas dans les métiers qui
recrutent voilà les quelques pistes que
nous pouvons nous vous dessiner madame
la Première ministre vous demandez du
temps pour la concertation vous avez une
proposition nos lignes rouges à vous de
faire preuve de courage
la parole est à Madame Élodie jacky est
la forge pour le groupe démocrate modem
et indépendant pour une durée de 15
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre madame la ministre
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
il y a un an à quelques jours près la
France ouvrait les portes du Panthéon à
Joséphine Baker 6e femme à y prendre
place après Simone Veil elle est
l'incarnation d'une intégration voulue
et réussie grand artiste de music hall
humaniste et femme de coeur elle fut
avant tout une grande patriote
sous-lieutenant engagé au sein des
Forces françaises libres et lorsqu'elle
était félicitée pour pour son action
elle répondait la France m'a ouvert les
bras je ne fais que lui rendre ce
qu'elle m'a donné par cette introduction
je souhaitais rappeler que nombre
d'autres Joséphine existent même si
l'histoire ne leur a pas rendu les mêmes
honneurs
chers collègues nous vivons actuellement
une époque troublée une guerre a lieu à
nos portes après qu'une pandémie est
déstabilisée durablement l'économie
mondiale
la crise énergétique est doublée d'une
crise climatique majeure une montée de
l'inflation un citoyen et l'incertitude
la tentation du repli sur soi et la peur
saisissent les populations
ce débat que nous avons aujourd'hui et
je remercie le gouvernement de l'avoir
organisé nous oblige à prendre en
considération la situation actuelle
mais en réalité la situation la question
est toujours la même comment conjuguer
le principe universel de la libre
circulation avec de l'autre côté le
principe du libre choix des peuples et
de leur gouvernante de disposer
librement de leur frontières
cet équilibre est difficile à trouver je
le conseille certains souhaitant la fin
irréaliste des frontières d'autres
voulant construire des murs tout aussi
illusoire entre les pays
nous devons à nos compatriotes de
métropoles et des Outre-mer de chercher
ce chemin d'équilibre les Français
attendent des réponses nous les savons
exigeants
la dernière loi que nous avons votée en
2018 a produit des résultats et à
entraîner une forte progression des
éloignements entre 2017 et 2019 avant la
crise du covid c'est mieux que ce que
font nos voisins européens mais
évidemment ce n'est pas suffisant c'est
la raison pour laquelle notre groupe
aborde le prochain projet de loi sur
l'immigration avec beaucoup de
pragmatisme mais aussi beaucoup
d'humanité pour le groupe démocrate
comme je l'avais dit en 2018 nous devons
avoir une politique d'immigration et
d'intégration à la fois humaine et
opérante parce que l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre c'est pour nous la clé d'une
législation réussie
sans ces deux bras pour accueillir chez
nous ceux qui ont besoin de notre
protection ceux qui sont une chance ou
un soutien pour notre activité
économique ce qui viennent s'enrichir de
nos savoirs et faire rayonner notre pays
à l'international sans cette action
exigeante nous risquons de renforcer la
défiance de certains de nos concitoyens
de réveiller des sentiments de rejet et
d'accentuer des fractures dans notre
société
la première réponse est européenne vous
l'avez indiquée madame la Première
ministre en effet une organisation
régionale telle que l'Union européenne
et a fortiori un état ne peuvent pas
espérer maîtriser seul les mouvements
migratoires les concernant ce qui
n'enlève rien à la nécessité de
politique nationale pertinente
l'exemple récent de l'océan vakking en
est une parfaite illustration les trois
semaines d'errance du navire qui a fini
par trouver refuge en France nous
rappelle qu'il faut impérativement
harmoniser les conditions d'entrée d'une
part mais aussi renforcer notre capacité
à mettre en œuvre les droits humains
d'autres parts
pourtant en 2018 des lignes avaient été
tracées sur ce point je tiens à s'élever
du travail riche et fourni de notre
groupe en particulier celui mené par
Marielle de Sarnez alors présidente de
la commission des affaires étrangères
qui rappelait alors à juste titre que la
stratégie que nous devons mener est
européenne diplomatique de développement
par le biais d'une vision à long terme à
cet égard elle encourageait un objectif
premier harmonisé nos pratiques
aujourd'hui cette convergence européenne
tant attendue de l'asile doit enfin être
mise en oeuvre sous forme de coopération
renforcée si nécessaire entre État
membre d'accord pour avancer ensemble
en matière de droit d'asile nous savons
tous que si le régime d'asile européen
commun fixe des normes minimales
communes applicables au traitement des
demandeurs d'asile ces derniers ne font
pas l'objet d'un traitement uniforme et
des taux de reconnaissance varie d'un
État membre à l'autre cela entraîne une
course au droit d'asile qui montre
combien l'harmonisation des procédures
et des normes en matière d'asile
nécessaire
en matière de partenariat global et
équilibré avec les pays d'origine et de
transit c'est une évidence notre gestion
des flux migratoires qui de soi qui doit
se faire à l'échelle européenne nous
impose de regarder au-delà de nos
frontières afin de permettre à ces
femmes ces enfants ces hommes qui fient
leur pays d'avoir le choix celui de
rester là où ils sont nés là où leur
famille est installée là où est leur
culture leur identité
à l'échelle nationale il est entre
autres indispensable que nous
poursuivions nos efforts pour réduire
les délais de traitement de la demande
d'asile c'est ainsi que nous permettrons
bénéficier de la protection
internationale de s'inscrire plus
rapidement dans un parcours
d'intégration sans perdre de temps et
c'est ainsi également que nous pourrons
dans le cas d'un rejet de la demande
opéré plus rapidement un retour effectif
des déboutés vers le pays d'origine
c'était l'objectif de la loi 2018 dont
il faut je crois interroger et évaluer
les résultats à l'aune également de sa
courte période d'application en effet
promulgué en 2018 cette loi n'a pu voir
ses effets qu'en 2019 2020 et 2021 étant
impactés par la crise de sanitaire comme
vous le savez ensuite il est essentiel
d'avoir une politique d'intégration
renforcée cela passe par l'acquisition
de la langue et par le travail François
Bayrou disait juste titre il y a
quelques jours qu'on devrait exiger deux
choses la maîtrise de la langue et de la
garantie de la volonté de s'intégrer de
participer un pays avec son mode de vie
et deuxièmement la volonté de s'engager
dans le travail pour gagner sa vie
aujourd'hui 75% des étrangers
signataires du contrat d'intégration
républicaine le SIR atteignent le niveau
requis à l'issue de la formation
obligatoire donnée par l'Office français
de l'immigration et de l'intégration
l'offi ce chiffre est bon même s'il est
encore insuffisant malgré tout la teinte
d'un niveau de langue n'est pas exigé
pour obtenir un titre de séjour la seule
obligation étant de suivre avec assudité
certes les formations civiques et
linguististes organisées par le fit dans
le cadre du contrat d'intégration
républicaine nous devons donc passer
d'une obligation de moyens à une
obligation de résultats il nous semble
nécessaire que le futur projet loi sur
l'immigration comporte des mesures
volontaristes en la matière
par ailleurs le travail doit de
redevenir le premier lieu de
l'intégration des étrangers quelle est
la situation aujourd'hui ça a été
rappelée par le ministre du Travail le
taux de chômage des immigrés et de 14,6%
contre 8,3 pour les personnes nées en
France et le taux d'emploi des immigrés
et seulement de 58,5% contre 66,4 pour
les personnes nées dans un dans le pays
en particulier je tiens à signaler pour
les femmes avec un différentiel qui va
jusqu'à 15 points entre femmes immigrées
et femmes né en France plusieurs
dispositifs existent pour favoriser
l'intégration des réfugiés en
particulier le dispositif
d'accompagnement global et
individualiser des réfugiés mais
aujourd'hui trop de travailleurs
étrangers qui contribuent à l'économie
de notre pays sont installés et
maintenus dans le non droit où
l'illégalité ils ne peuvent pas dès lors
rejoindre un parcours d'intégration
c'est pourquoi je le dis avec force au
nom de mon groupe
nous voulons que l'hypogrisie cesse pour
que ces trappes à illégalité
disparaissent il faut des mesures pour
que les travailleurs étrangers eux-mêmes
afin de faciliter leur accès au travail
dans des situations bien définies et
déterminées et des mesures envers les
employeurs afin qu'ils participent mieux
à l'état gras science sociale de leur
salarié cela passe entre autres par des
mesures de régulation je pense notamment
secteur des plateformes de transport et
de et de livraison par des réponses
adaptées aux métiers en tension aux
besoins des entreprises en matière de
profil très qualifiés et si nécessaire
par des sanctions dissuasives et
appliquées en cas d'emploi d'un étranger
clandestin
né en 2005 le CZ le code de l'entrée et
du séjour des étrangers et du droit
d'asile peut-être le code le plus épais
de notre droit a connu de nombreux
toilettages depuis la fin des années 80
l'immigration a connu 21 lois 21 lois en
32 ans c'est certainement trop
reconnaissons le il existe très peu de
domaines dans lesquels on les GIF faire
autant
cela doit nous conduire à l'humilité je
crois quelle que soit notre place dans
l'hémicycle
monsieur le ministre vous entendez
aujourd'hui ouvrir une nouvelle page
vous avez choisi de mener plusieurs
chantiers renforcer notre efficacité
pour lutter contre les menaces à l'ordre
public et à l'immigration irrégulière
nous nous réjouissons que la lutte
contre les passeurs qui exploite la
détresse humaine en face partie engager
une réforme structurelle de notre
système d'asile en effet le traitement
des demandes d'asile est encore beaucoup
trop long et source d'un trop grand
contentieux sur ce point il est
important que les collectivités locales
soient des partenaires actifs et de
relais sans lequel les représentants de
sur lesquels les représentants de l'État
devront s'appuyer car sans l'échelle
locale rien ne se fera cependant il
faudra être attentif pour les OCC à ne
pas déséquilibrer le système en voulant
aller trop vite sans respecter les
droits du recours en appel d'une
décision
vous entendez également renforcer les
exigences d'intégration par la langue et
le travail nous en sommes satisfaits je
le disais tout à l'heure il ne peut y
avoir d'intégration sans maîtrise de la
langue et un accès au travail surtout
ces sujets nous aurons le temps de
travailler ensemble pour arriver à
l'équilibre et à l'efficacité car nous
croyons injuste équilibre celui-ci est
possible et nécessaire un humanisme
lucide adapté et exigeant c'est pourquoi
nous serons force de proposition nous
veillerons à ce que nos valeurs soient
préservées l'accueil et l'intégration
nous pourront se faire qu'en étant
exigeant sur les modalités de mise en
oeuvre ce sont les seules clés d'une
acceptation partout de notre devoir
d'accueil et ainsi d'un climat apaisé
dans notre pays où chacun pourra trouver
sa place
la migration n'est pas un phénomène dont
nous devons avoir peur elle existe
depuis la nuit des temps vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur ministre de l'Intérieur
qui d'entre nous n'a d'ailleurs pas un
parent un ami un collègue qui n'est pas
d'origine française qui d'entre nous ne
voient pas aussi combien la France a pu
s'enrichir de cette diversité alors
trouvons ensemble le courage de donner
les moyens à ceux qui ont toutes
légitimité à rester dans notre pays de
le faire dans les meilleures conditions
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Boris Vallot
pour le groupe socialiste et à parenté
pour une durée de 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues vous nous
invitez aujourd'hui à débattre de la
politique d'immigration de la France un
débat dont nous souhaitons qu'il puisse
être guidé par la mesure la vérité et la
fidélité à ce qu'est la France dans son
histoire la République dans les
principes qu'il a fondent l'État de
droit dans les règles qui le gouvernent
nous sommes ni dans l'obsession ni dans
l'aveuglement ni des ni face au défi de
l'immigration ni posture viril et en
définitive veine qui finissent par
désespérer les Français nous savons que
sans être au sommet de leur
préoccupations et de leurs difficultés
quotidiennes la question migratoire Tao
de les Françaises et les Français dans
un moment d'angoisse existentielle et
même culturels tentent à beaucoup
l'avenir est incertain le présent
difficile l'idéal d'intégration malmenée
disons-le aussi nettement de à l'égard
de la politique nous leur devons un
débat honnête et juste qui nous autorise
en inkipit et en lointain écho à
Jean-Pierre chevenant il y a 25 ans a
rappelé que parler des étrangers c'est
aussi une autre manière de parler de la
France oui de parler de la France et des
Français de rappeler que le peuple
français ne s'est jamais défini par la
souche mais par le bonheur d'être
ensemble en donnant sens à son histoire
et j'ajouterai par la grande ébène
ambition de construire ensemble une
nation d'ego la France marche au mélange
elle est le creuset fertile duquel
jaillit le meilleur les visages des
premiers de corvées qui se sont révélés
dans la crise les visages de celles et
de ceux
issus de tous les pays qui portent haut
et de bien des manières les couleurs de
notre pays
je dis à nos compatriotes français dont
les aïeux furent un moment de leur
histoire personnelle des étrangers je
leur dis c'est évident ce qui me fait
mal de devoir rappeler parce que
d'autres la contestent sur ces bancs
vous êtes français on peut aimer la
France et la terre de ses ancêtres
peut-être est-ce même là le cœur de
l'universalisme républicain comme le
disait Aimé Césaire l'universel riche de
tout le particulier riche de tous les
particuliers un débat honnête qui nous
oblige aussi à dire que l'immigration
n'est pas une opinion mais une réalité
historique économique sociale humaine
surtout et qu'elle est aussi devant nous
oui l'immigration phénomène mondiale a
connu au plan mondial une augmentation
plan européen au plan français sous
l'effet conjugués des désordres
géostratégiques des guerres de la
mondialisation du réchauffement
climatique il y a 1000 raisons de rester
chez soi il en a quelques-unes seulement
de partir
une augmentation néanmoins beaucoup plus
modeste en France que dans d'autres pays
de l'Union européenne bien loin des
fantasmes assassins de la submersion du
tsunami migratoire ou du grand
emplacement et même de ce fantasme de
l'appel d'air François errant professeur
au Collège de France en fait la
démonstration méthodique cette hausse
est pour moitié le fait d'une
immigration estudiante tant mieux pour
un quart et le fait de l'immigration du
travail encouragé par le visa talent et
pour un cas également d'une immigration
au titre du droit d'asile le reste n'est
que mensonge et c'est à dire qu'il n'y
aurait aucune difficulté au contraire au
cœur du malaise migratoire il y a les
discours de haine qui nous donne la
nausée
et il y a aussi les situations
d'indignité de non-droits pour des
milliers de femmes d'hommes d'enfants
jetés à la rue et autant de vie briser
l'inflation incontrôlée des occultes
félivrés sans discernement et de
surcroît rarement exécutés et à elle
seule le témoignage de l'échec de notre
système d'asile d'immigration ou plutôt
de sa mise en échec par votre
gouvernement il accueille mal il protège
mal et reconduit mal et l'intégration
peine à se déployer madame la Première
ministre rend cette manière matière
comme en beaucoup d'autres les Français
réclament le respect de l'ordre
républicain et vous avez organisé le
désordre dans la République un droit des
étrangers illisibles et
incompréhensibles un empilement
désordonné de réforme successives des
procédures inefficaces des instructions
ubues des délais intenables un manque
accablant de moyens des préfectures une
dimétarialisation dysfonctionnelle des
tribunaux administratifs emboliser une
politique d'éloignement défaillante la
crise passion des relations
diplomatiques avec les pays d'origine
des collectivités venant tant bien que
mal au secours la France de l'État c'est
le constat accablant dressé par le
rapport du sénateur buffet et je le dis
accablé c'est aussi votre bilan une
politique migratoire maîtrisée c'est une
politique migratoire claire applicable
et appliquée commencez par régler ses
ordres qui relèvent du pouvoir
réglementaire d'instructions
ministérielle de l'organisation de
l'État redonner du sens à une politique
qui n'en a plus et venez peut-être nous
présenter une 20e 29e loi sur ce sujet
en 40 ans c'est en tout cas le préalable
et une refondation en profondeur de
notre politique migratoire sur lequel
bâtir un consensus républicain que je
crois possible il y a d'abord de ce
point de vue là ce qui pour nous n'est
pas négociable parce qu'il s'agit de
droit de droits humains et de
conventions internationales il y a au
premier rang le droit d'Asie notre
héritage et notre honneur que vous avez
prétendu tant de fois défendre et que
vous avez tant de fois abîmé il doit
être pleinement effective ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui et ce que vos
projets risquent encore de compromettre
avec le juge unique avec avec
l'accélération des procédures avec les
visio audiences il y a ensuite le droit
à la vie privée et familiale le droit au
regroupement familial qui procède de la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et qui n'a cessé dessus durcir
en droit comment faire dans
l'instruction ou l'absence d'instruction
des demandes il y a la protection des
mineurs isolés non accompagnés qui
demeure non déplaisent des mineurs
auxquels on doit la protection de
l'enfance avant que d'être des étrangers
il y a le droit à la santé le maintien
de l'aide médicale d'État pour des
motifs humanitaires bien compris autant
que sanitaire et il y a enfin
l'inconditionnalité de l'accueil selon
lequel toute personne présente sur notre
territoire doit pouvoir bénéficier d'un
hébergement et d'un accompagnement
sanitaire et social adapté à cette
situation nous avons réussi à faire
qu'aucun réfugié du crâne de Dante à la
rue comment pourrions-nous accepter que
les Afghans ils passent des semaines
l'idée selon laquelle il faudrait rendre
invivable la vie des étrangers être
méchants avec les méchants est indigne
et la circulaire du 17 novembre très
répressive envoyée au préfet de ce point
de vue particulièrement préoccupante un
étranger c'est le droit européen son
droit ni titre n'est pas pour autant un
délinquant il est ensuite ce qui peut
être débattu nous sommes favorables et
des mesures ambitieuses de
régularisation par le travail des
étrangers présent sur notre territoire
comme à une réflexion sur le droit à
l'immigration économique d'abord parce
que nous considérons que la régulation
par le travail est bénéfique à tous les
travailleurs là où le travail illégal
cultive la précarité la concurrence
déloyale contraint d'accepter d'indignes
conditions de travail et de rémunération
et de demeurer ainsi à la merci de
réseau divers qu'il faut combattre sans
relâche ensuite parce que nous ne
pensons est défendons l'idée que le
travail digne est l'un des ressorts de
l'intégration économique et sociale que
le processus d'intégration est au cœur
de la constitution du peuple français
comme nation que la défense du travail
et de valeur est consubstantielle du
projet émancipateur de la gauche nous
savons d'expérience par ailleurs que le
talent ne connaît pas les frontières de
manière générale nous sommes favorables
à une politique d'intégration
volontariste des primes arrivants et en
particulier des femmes quel que soit
leur droit de leur droit durable au
séjour par l'emploi donc mais aussi par
l'éducation par l'enseignement du
français par la formation
professionnelle par la culture par
l'accélation par le logement
au contenteur de l'intégration qui ne
veulent plus même y croire aveugle aux
immenses réussites dont nous sommes
pourtant chaque jour les témoins nous
disons refusés à toute force et
discriminations qui minent l'intégration
la cohésion nationale et nourrissent le
ressentiment de celles et de ceux
qu'elle frappent refuser la ségrégation
scolaire refusait les quartiers goto
fait de l'hospitalité une façon d'être
enfin puisque un dégât d'un débat
viendra sur un texte où nous avons
quelques-unes des grandes lignes donnons
quelques principes qui devraient selon
nous guider
j'ai donc notamment pour un titre de
séjour de plein droit plus réel comme
garantie d'un traitement équitable dans
tous les départements et de la bonne
intégration des travailleurs étrangers
nous demandons la fin du pouvoir de
l'employeur dans les délivrance du titre
du séjour le droit à la formation
professionnelle et linguistique et
l'ensemble des droits afférents y
compris les droits sociaux les droits
sanitaires et le droit regroupement
familial
au-delà de cette question nous appelons
un changement de méthode et la
construction de protection
complémentaire nous plaidons pour une
instruction à 360 degrés par laquelle
serait examinée par les préfectures dès
la première demande l'ensemble des
motifs qui pourraient fonder la
délivrance du titre de séjour un
changement de cadre juridique ensuite
nous parrait nécessaire certains besoins
de protection humanitaire nous relèvent
d'évidences pas du droit d'asile et
peuvent concerner beaucoup de celles que
nous appelons les Nini ni reconductibles
ni régularisable qui demeure dans des
situations de non-droit dont nous ne
pouvons nous satisfaire nous avons
besoin d'une protection humanitaire
complémentaire ouvrant droit au séjour
donc plaidons aussi pour un nouveau
cadre normatif pour la protection des
déplacés environnementaux alors que la
crise annonciatrice de mouvement de
population nouveau et devant nous pour
agir efficacement à l'échelle européenne
il faut réformer le système de Schengen
et que la France n'affaiblisse pas sa
crédibilité en accueillant seulement 38
des 3000 étrangers qu'elle était censée
accueillir sur son sol dans le cadre de
la répartition européenne c'est par une
politique d'asile et d'immigration
respectueuse des droits des étrangers
par des règles claires des procédures
efficaces par les dignités de l'accueil
par le respect de l'ordre public et
social par une politique volontariste
d'intégration que viendra la régulation
et la maîtrise des flux migratoire
attendue par les Français les murs
administratifs que vous avez dressé
n'arrêtent rien ils enferment dans des
situations de non-droits et dans des
accueils indignes remettez d'abord de
l'ordre dans le désordre actuel voilà ce
qu'attendent les Français ayant de
l'ambition et de l'humanité comme nos
voisins allemands ont été capables de le
faire accueillant un million de réfugiés
il disait nous y arriverons
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
marchangeli pour le groupe horizon et à
parenté pour une durée de 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre Madame et Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues
avec l'amour d'une mère la vie vous fait
à l'aube une promesse qu'elle ne tient
jamais
cela fait bien trop longtemps que la
mère patrie la France fait des promesses
à temps d'enfants de ce monde sans
pouvoir les tenir
ce n'est pas faute d'avoir
collectivement tenté de trouver le juste
point d'équilibre restez fidèle à notre
tradition d'asile accueillir les
personnes qui fuient de terribles
conflits
tout en s'assurant que nous sommes en
capacité de les intégrer dignement de
préserver la cohésion sociale de
protéger notre nation
le temps est venu d'être réaliste d'être
pragmatique oui nous avons besoin
d'immigration mais celle-ci ne saurait
conduire à un délitement de nos valeurs
non elle ne saurait conduire à
s'éloigner de l'idée que nous faisons de
la France du respect et de la défense de
nos valeurs fondamentales celles qui
structure notre pays les valeurs de la
République
malgré des plus de 20 lois votées dans
cette hémicycle depuis 1986 nous voici
une nouvelle fois à débattre de ce sujet
qui pour des raisons à la fois
idéologiques mais aussi souvent intime
nous anime chacun profondément et
conduisent malheureusement certains se
muraient dans des postures regrettables
pour que chacun tente de sortir de ses
postures commençons par nous accorder
sur un diagnostic notre pays compte
aujourd'hui 10,3% d'immigrés soit 7
millions de personnes la dynamique
constatée s'agissant du solde migratoire
se confirme avec en moyenne 200 000
immigrés supplémentaires chaque année
dans notre pays
pour l'Europe la question migratoire est
donc avant tout une question de
résilience de long terme elle ne saurait
se poser sans tenir compte de la
conjoncture géopolitique dans la
prévisibilité est extrêmement variable
qu'il s'agisse de guerre de crise
économique et bientôt des effets des
changements climatiques
l'Afrique comptera selon certaines
projections 4 milliards d'habitants en
2100 contre 650 millions en Europe avec
une population plus jeune qu'ici
face à ce vertige démographique notre
système actuel européen et national et
trop fragile et il doit être adapté pour
préserver demain la cohésion nationale
dès aujourd'hui cette afflux
significative contribue à mettre notre
système d'intégration sous tension nos
services publics qui supportent
directement ou indirectement cette
charge mais aussi la société française
tout entière
nos capacités d'intégration ont atteint
leur limite en termes de logement
d'abord chaque soir les services
d'hébergement d'urgence sont contraints
de refuser nombre de personnes faute de
place en matière d'éducation la France
persiste en bas des classements bizarres
et je crois qu'il n'est même pas la
peine d'évoquer la situation dans
laquelle se trouve nos hôpitaux alors
que la crise sanitaire se poursuit à
cela s'ajoute notre incapacité à
exécuter les obligations de quitter le
territoire dans font l'objet un certain
nombre d'étrangers
pour autant d'un point de vue économique
force est de reconnaître que la France
peine à se passer de l'immigration
elle a toujours rempli un rôle de
compensation là où les besoins n'étaient
pas satisfaits par la population locale
je parle surtout des métiers peu
qualifiés pénibles où il faut le dire
les employeurs peinent à trouver la main
d'oeuvre locale qui accepte de pouvoir
ses emplois enfin il me semble que nous
pouvons nous accorder tous pour dire que
notre droit et nos politiques
d'immigration sont devenues illisibles
et source de frustration pour les
étrangers pour les fonctionnaires pour
les juges et pour les Français qui n'en
comprennent ni la logique ni l'apparente
impuissance si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
un seul chiffre vous en convaincra il y
a 186 titres de séjour en France alors
qu'il n'y a que quatre motifs de séjour
sur notre territoire hors tourisme
face à ces défis il faut une réelle
stratégie migratoire globale pour ne
plus subir l'immigration il est
aujourd'hui indispensable de reprendre
le contrôle et de maîtriser
l'immigration dans notre pays nous
devons tendre vers un système où nous
serons capables de tarir les flux subis
tout en attirant chez nous les talents
et les forces vivent adaptés
et ont un peu plus clair
plus d'immigrations choisies moins
d'immigration subie concrètement cela
repose sur cinq piliers incontournables
d'abord agir en amont pour prévenir les
flux irréguliers depuis la création de
l'espace Schengen agir en la matière
n'aurait que peu de sens il faut qu'une
action collective européenne se déploie
aux côtés bien sûr d'une stratégie
nationale de protection de nos
frontières
au niveau européen donc il nous faut
rendre désormais obligatoire le dépôt de
la demande d'asile des ressortissants
des pays sûrs auprès des postes des
États membres de l'UE situés dans leur
pays de résidence tout ressortissant
d'un pays sûr qui n'aurait pas satisfait
à cette obligation et souhaiterait
déposer sa demande d'asile une fois
entrée dans l'espace Schengen serait
immédiatement refoulé à cela doit
s'ajouter une politique interne très
ferme sur la délivrance de visa trop
d'étrangers se maintiennent sur notre
territoire malgré l'expiration de la
validité validité de ces derniers pour
limiter ce nombre il nous semble
nécessaire de durcir les conditions
d'octroi en particulier de certains
titres tels que celui d’étranger malade
ensuite simplifier le droit au séjour
pour mieux accueillir et mieux éloigner
notre droit au séjour ce droit d'être
lisible par toute et par tous afin qu'il
soit mieux compris et mieux appliquer
pour cela notre groupe défunt une
simplification massive du paysage des
titres et il nous apparaît nécessaire
d'aller au bout de cette démarche en
permettant l'administration de statuer
en une fois son intégralité du droit au
séjour des demandeurs cela permettra
naturellement d'accélérer l'instruction
de simplifier le contentieux et infiner
de mieux accueillir ou de mieux éloigner
mieux accueillir c'est aussi mieux
intégré en conditionnant la délivrance
c'est le renouvellement des titres de
séjour au respect des valeurs qui
fondent notre République cela implique
je le crois profondément un
apprentissage exigeant de la langue
française la maîtrise de la langue est
Anne incontournable il faut que nous
réhaussions nos exigences à la matière
au risque de voir un délitement lent
mais si dangereux de notre culture
évidemment cela va de pair avec
l'intégration par le travail il nous
faut attirer les compétences dans le
pays manque et nous soutenons
l'instauration de quotas de compétences
pour pouvoir les métiers en tension cela
pourrait également passer par
l'ouverture du passeport talent au
professionnel du secteur de la santé
sous réserve qui s'installe dans des
zones en tension
parler notre langue contribuer à notre
économie bien sûr mais cela doit
s'accompagner d'un contrôle exigeant de
l'adhésion individuel et collective aux
valeurs de notre République en outre
nous croyons profondément qu'il est
désormais temps d'européaniser
complètement une politique de l'asile
qui aujourd'hui dysfonctionne c'est un
choix déterminant qui doit s'opérer nous
avons atteint aujourd'hui à mi-chemin
peu performant un peu de politique
nationale un peu de politique européenne
groupe HORIZONS parce que nous croyons
profondément à la force de l'Union
européenne nous faisons le choix d'une
politique d'asile communautaire avec une
agence européenne de l'asile une cour
européenne du droit d'asile et d'un
monopole de l'agence contexte pour
éloigner les étrangers déboutés vers
leur pays d'origine
enfin il est absolument indispote
indispensable de muscler notre stratégie
d'éloignement or pour une fois si j'ose
dire ce n'est pas notre arsenal
juridique qui manque déficience mais
bien notre capacité à réellement
éloigner les personnes concernées nous
n'avons donc qu'une seule option
crédible agir sur les pays sources en
conditionnant l'aide au développement à
la coopération en matière de réadmission
et limiter drastiquement le taux et la
durée de délivrance des visas nous ne
pouvons continuer à financer massivement
des projets structurants dans ces pays
sans exiger une coopération efficace en
matière de réadmission le durcissement
de notre politique éloignement et
d'expulsion est une absolue nécessité et
nous espérons qu'elle trouvera une
traduction claire et non équivoque dans
le futur projet de loi vous l'aurez
compris nous attendons beaucoup du
projet de loi à venir nous espérons
profondément que l'équilibre entre
humanité et fermeté nos cultura pas un
certain nombre de questions essentielles
telles que le renforcement du mécanisme
de double peine ou encore la question
des mineurs non accompagnés
notre souhait pourrait donc se résumer
ainsi
soyons ferme pour rester en capacité de
tenir notre promesse celle d'une France
qui accueille dignement celles et ceux
qui comme nous sont profondément
attachés aux valeurs de notre République
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
présidente
et bien pensant pour vous ce sont des
injures pour nous c'est une boussole car
oui la fraternité est constitutive de
notre contrat social si elle trouve nos
côtés de la liberté et de l'égalité dans
le triptyque de la devise républicaine
ce n'est pas pour demeurer simplement
graver en lettres creuse au fronton de
nos mairies c'est pour guider notre
action alors oui nous assumons notre
préférence pour l'humanité valeur
première qui ne peut être équidistante
d'aucune prétendue fermeté oui la
compassion la bienveillance l'empathie
sont des émotions politiques au même
titre que l'aspiration à la justice ou à
la dignité vous préparez un nouveau
texte une centaine d'autres ont déjà été
votées depuis la Libération
celui-ci n'échappera pas à la règle
tragiquement banalisée du durcissement
croissant et des restrictions
supplémentaires des conditions d'accueil
puisque ces débats se répètent sans
cesse c'est qu'ils n'ont servi à rien
nous vous proposons donc de changer de
philosophie d'abord conjurer la peur et
combattre les mensonges
ce débat il existe ici et dans le pays
depuis 50 ans qu'il y a une extrême
droite organisée ils se fonde sur un
ressort unique la peur le FN puis le RN
et ses variant l'entretiennent
l'organise parfois avec la complaisance
cynique des gouvernants leur message au
fond peut se résumer à cette formule
ayez peur et laissez-nous faire le reste
ainsi on toujours fonctionner les
fascisme la peur c'est l'ennemi intime
de la démocratie parce qu'elle préfigure
l'obéissance aveugle le repli sur soi la
violence pour surmonter les peurs il ne
faut pas ligner ou les esquiver mais les
ramener lucidement à ce qu'elles sont
si certains de nos compatriotes voient
dans l'immigration la cause des malheurs
du pays et de leur propre sort c'est
parce qu'on leur désigne un bouc
émissaire facile symbole de cette peur
au cours du jeûne 21e siècle il aura été
construit 40 000 km de mur autant que la
circonférence de la planète
on a fait des victimes de la guerre ou
de la misère les coupables des mots
d'une France déclassés par 30 ans de
néolibéralisme fracturé par les
inégalités minées par les injustices
désertés par les services publics et
trop souvent impuissante face au
désordre du monde notamment devant le
péril climatique à l'oeuvre alors assez
naturellement l'opinion surestime de 15
points le poids des migrations en France
c'est le résultat d'un débat public
englouti sous les thèmes et les termes
de l'extrême droite il n'y a plus de
chiffres plus de vérité seulement un
récit fantasmatique déroulé completement
par quelques grands médias dont ceux de
Monsieur Bolloré propagandiste en chef
de l'offensive raciste et xénophobe
alors sans crainte face à tous les
mensonges il nous faut dire la vérité
la vérité c'est que les migrations sont
une réalité permanente historique comme
tant d'autres phénomènes géographiques
humains sociologiques dire immigration
zéro n'a par conséquent aucun sens la
vérité c'est l'immigration ne concerne
que 3,5 % de la population mondiale et
se font pour une part conséquente entre
pays du Sud et que toute la misère du
monde reste bien concentré là où elle
est les plus pauvres des pays pauvres
n'accédant quasiment jamais à nos portes
la vérité c'est qu'il faut nous préparer
aux migrations climatiques qui sont l'un
des grands défis du réchauffement
la vérité c'est que verrouiller les
frontières n'empêche pas les migrations
qui ont changé d'échelle cela ne fait
qu'augmenter les drames les morts
regardons avec colère et chagrin ces
dizaines de milliers de morts en
Méditerranée ou en mer de manche et ceux
qui suivront si nous persévérons dans
une orientation politique aussi inapte
qui nous mène toute politique qui ne se
préoccuperait pas d'abord de sauver des
vies humaines revient à s'inscrire dans
une forme de complicité d'un crime que
nos sociétés infligent à l'humanité à
certains de nos semblables
la vérité c'est qu'au début de la
pandémie le taux de mortalité parmi les
immigrés était neuf fois plus élevés que
pour le reste de la population parce
qu'ils acceptent plus difficilement aux
soins vivent davantage dans les
conditions de précarité et de
promiscuité mais aussi parce qu'ils
occupent bien plus les emplois dit
essentiels où sont passés vos
applaudissements quotidiens à leur égard
la vérité c'est que les conditions de
traitement des exilés dans notre pays
des centres de rétention au camp de
fortune sont indignes près de Dunkerque
où j'étais il y a quelques semaines les
humanitaires vous réclament un robinet
d'eau potable juste un robinet d'eau
potable
la vérité c'est que 50% des exilés dans
le monde et un tiers en Europe sont des
enfants
70% de ceux qui sont évalués se voient
refuser une prise en charge au titre de
la protection de l'enfance au motif
qu'il ne serait pas mineur ou isolé
la vérité c'est que faire des exilés des
variables d'ajustements économiques
selon les niveaux de métier selon les
niveaux de tension de tel ou tel métier
revient à les déshumaniser aller privé
de dignité et c'est une rupture grave
dans les principes du droit du travail
la vérité c'est qu'une politique
d'accueil digne ne provoquera pas
l'appel d'air que vous agitez tel un
épouvantail en face de toute tentative
de politique humaniste
ceux qui risquent leur vie s'arrachent à
leur terre à leurs proches de le font
pas avec une revue de presse spécialisée
en droit social et migratoire sous le
bras la vérité c'est qu'il y a en
revanche des migrants dont vous ne
parlez pas les migrants de la finance à
eux vous accordez d'ailleurs facilement
la qualité d'exilé ce sont les évadés
fiscaux qui eux nous coûtent une part
conséquente de la richesse nationale qui
eux abusent notre générosité qui eux
choisissent le séparatisme à coup de
millions c'est en somme la lutte des
classes version garde frontières que
vous nous proposez avec les plus riches
et la finance vous êtes nos borders vous
affirmez sans cesse votre amour des
entrepreneurs et de la valeur travail la
vérité c'est que nous vous arrivons
créent plus d'emplois qu'il n'en
occupent les étrangers participent à 15%
des créations d'entreprises en France
la vérité c'est que notre système de
l'asile est toujours complexe et
défaillant il se dégrade constamment la
loi ne voit pas le demandeur d'asile
comme un persécuté mais comme un
potentiel tricheur la vérité c'est que
l'intégration ne peut être une simple
injonction elle est un processus de
socialisation qui implique une
progression dans le temps c'est l'action
politique qui peut créer les conditions
de cette intégration en levant les
obstacles économiques sociaux éducatifs
linguistique culturel et civique
chers collègues choisissons la confiance
j'ai entendu Madame Le Pen et en fait
vous n'aimez pas la France vous n'aimez
pas la France parce que vous la voyez
faible incapable de rayonner de se
transformer vous n'aimez pas son
histoire faite de mélange et de
dépassement nous nous croyons que l'on
peut faire France de tout bois parce que
c'est notre histoire notre richesse
notre génie même que de fabriquer sans
cesse une culture nourrie par d'autres
ne soyons pas une nation frileuse
repliée sur elle-même comme si elle
n'avait pas su trouver dans son histoire
la force de se renouveler de se
réinventer de se régénérer et donc de se
renforcer
[Applaudissements]
oui nous croyons qu'une France généreuse
accueillante fraternelle est une France
plus forte face aux urgences du présent
et au grand défi de l'avenir
chers collègues la France et le plus
ancien pays d'immigration en Europe
c'est notre tradition depuis le 18e
siècle aujourd'hui elle n'est que le
cinquième pays européen par le nombre de
ces étrangers où est donc votre
submersion migratoire avoir confiance
c'est régulariser ceux qui travaillent
cotisent payent des impôts avoir
confiance c'est attiré ici des milliers
d'étudiants qui construisent un lien
intellectuel scientifique technique
durable avec notre pays avoir confiance
ces chérir la générosité et la
fraternité en mettant fin au harcèlement
des humanitaires et aux délits de
solidarité
avoir confiance c'est garantir l'accès
aux droits pour tous les exilés avoir
confiance ces dispenser à chacune et à
chacun les soins physiques et
psychologiques nécessaires
avoir confiance c'est refuser que les
groupes musculent remettent en cause la
liberté pédagogique fondement de l'école
républicaine et menace avec violence une
enseignante qui explique et montre à ses
étudiants la réalité des migrations
avoir confiance c'est sortir ce débat
sur l'immigration de la pression
électoraliste des pulsions des
surenchères plusieurs associations
proposent une convention citoyenne sur
les migrations voilà qui sortiraient de
la répétition compulsive des textes et
des vociférations stériles
avoir confiance c'est construire une
grande politique de l'inclusion qui
brise les plafonds de verre qui Combal
le racisme et les discriminations qui
refusent la signation à résidence le
chômage la précarité en confiance et en
vérité débarrasser des peurs et des
mensonges faisant vivre la fraternité
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Davy Riemann
pour le groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine pour une durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
président de bonsoir Monsieur mesdames
bonsoir madame la Première ministre
bonsoir c'est le président bonsoir chers
collègues bonsoir beaucoup de choses ont
été dites ce soir sur le sujet de
l'immigration j'ai entendu beaucoup de
personnes sur ces bons parler de
l'étranger
pour moi à l'étranger à la base c'est
quelqu'un qui a une autre nationalité
que celle de la France et pourtant
depuis tout à l'heure je dans beaucoup
de personnes parler que du continent
africain
à croire que le sujet majeur ce sont les
immigrés les exilés du continent
africain pour certaines personnes sur
c'est bon je te commande l'histoire
intrinsèque qu'il lit la France c'est le
continent africain l'histoire
intrinsèque qui lit l'Europe avec le
continent africain il faut pas oublier
ce qui abusent passer dans le passé nous
ne restons pas dans le passé mais nous
n'oublions pas à ceux qui se passe
la France comme l'Europe
doit beaucoup au continent africain
beaucoup d'entreprises prospère
aujourd'hui grâce aux ressources de ce
continent
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises
continuent à se développer grâce aux
ressources de ce continent mais pour
autant
leur avoir rendu cela au même niveau je
ne crois pas je me rappelle les mots de
l'ancien président feu Jacques Chirac
qui
nous avons fauté avec l'Afrique ce n'est
pas bien ce que nous avons fait je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui se passe avec les
exilés et par les immigrés puisque la
plupart du temps ce sont des exilés qui
arrivent sur nos territoires parce que
dans le besoin il fait la misère il fut
la guerre
aujourd'hui on doit parler plutôt de
politique d'accueil que de politique
d'immigration sommes-nous en capacité
d'accueillir ces gens-là dignement la
réponse est oui la France peut le faire
et la France doit le faire
j'ai entendu parler de chiffres de taux
de nombre de reconduites et encore des
chiffres et des chiffres sauf que des
affiches là il y a des hommes des femmes
des enfants
et même si nous raccourcis sont les
délais de procédure dans les tribunaux
ces hommes et ces femmes et ses enfants
seront toujours devant nous le temps que
ces dossiers sont traités dans les
tribunaux donc nous devons surtout
mettre à disposition les moyens
nécessaires à cuire ces personnes
alignement afin qu'on puisse traiter
leur dossier avec respect dignité et les
choix seront fait infinie c'est sûr quoi
je crois moi personnellement ensuite
le vrai problème en fait c'est celui de
la de celui et celle que nous
ressemblent pas je vais vous raconter
une anecdote suite à mon élection au
mois de juin je suis arrivé à
l'Assemblée et j'avais pas encore le
badge je suis arrivé au port de
l'Assemblée pour me renseigner donc je
peux pas rentrer j'ai sonné une personne
a sorti et je dis bonjour il m'a répondu
bonjour et la première chose qu'elle
médite avant même que je puisse
m'exprimer monsieur les livraisons c'est
de l'autre côté
[Musique]
sauf que tout le monde n'a pas la même
capacité et les mêmes réflexes
il faut qu'on comprenne ce qui peut se
passer lorsque des gens arrivent sont au
territoire et sont rejetés sont méprisés
parce qu'ils ne ressemble pas et ne pas
pas la même langue
il y a le célèbre auteur compositeur
artiste
qui disait ceci tout qui dit cela
puisqu'il a parmi nous il n'y a pas
d'intégration dans le rejet
et il a raison
lorsque l'autre arrive on se doit de lui
tendre la main de la cueillir dignement
de l'accompagner dans ses déboires
pourquoi on ne sait pas ce qui peut se
passer demain aujourd'hui la France a la
capacité à le faire demande c'est pas ce
qui pourrait se passer toutes ces hommes
et ces femmes qui font le métier que
d'autres ne veulent pas faire
aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas de
nationalité française et qui participent
à l'histoire de la France moi en tant
que le tramarin la Guyane aujourd'hui
est un territoire sans continent
sud-afrique issu d'américain qui a deux
frontières une à l'aise de Brésil une
Alouette sur une arme séparée par deux
fleuves vous pensez que lorsqu'on va
augmenter les reconduites à la frontière
de chaque côté ça va régler le problème
non
nous devons vraiment mettre en place une
réelle politique d'accueil sur le
territoire parler de des villes
frontières la Guyane sur le territoire
français hors Europe à être un
territoire avec des villes frontières
il faut bien l'entendre à ce titre là il
y a des dispositions bien précises à
prendre en compte et lorsque l'autre
fois pour l'autre nous avons demandé au
ministre de l'Intérieur de prendre en
compte ces réalités les deux proposer un
amendement pour renforcer les liens avec
les pays voisins ça n'a pas été je finis
mon propre président pour dire cela
Nelson Mandela disait ceci avoir peur
c'est normal la fronter ce qui nous fait
peur c'est encore mieux donc n'ayons pas
peur et affronté je vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
negelaine pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire pour
une durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame messieurs les ministres
monsieur le président de commission mes
chers collègues le débat qui nous
rassemble ce jour doit nous rappeler
apprendre une certaine hauteur et à
faire preuve de pragmatisme la
protection et la boussole qui doit
guider notre action et qui devra
éclairer la main du législateur lorsque
notre assemblée sera saisi du prochain
texte sur l'immigration
ce débat doit appeler à notre raison et
je suis persuadé qu'il est possible de
construire une bien meilleure politique
migratoire mieux régulée mieux contrôler
une politique plus ferme mais aussi plus
protectrice plus
utile pour notre société
je vais diviser mon propos sur deux
volets le volet intérieur déjà
l'actualité oblige les occultés F le
constat me semble clair et nous le
vérifions tous les jours il y a une
véritable carence en 2020 ont compté
plus de 107.000 au qtf et un taux
d'exécution de 6,9%
sur le seul premier semestre de ville
2021 ce taux serait de 6%. on ne peut
pas parler de fermeté dans ces
conditions
je rejoins les recommandations du
Conseil d'État en la matière il faut
simplifier le contentieux pour limiter
la multiplication des voix de recours
abusives lorsque les recours sont
rejetés mais que les étrangers restent
sur les territoires cela renforce le
sentiment d'inutilité de l'action des
magistrats pour rester dans l'efficacité
je dois
également parler de la gestion de le
champ de viking qui démontre certaines
failles qu'il faut parer il faut trouver
des solutions équilibrées si on prend
l'exemple des 26 sur 44 mineurs rescapés
de l'océan Viking ayant fugué leur lieu
d'accueil je pense qu'il faudrait
pouvoir trouver des lieux d'accueil
adaptés à ces mineurs dans le respect
des droits de l'homme mais avec une
surveillance accrue l'objectif est
également de protéger ses enfants on ne
peut pas les laisser seul dans la nature
sans accompagnement
enfin je vais aller plus loin sur
l'expulsion des étrangers délinquants ce
débat est sensible et toujours vicié par
une certaine hypocrisie il ne s'agit pas
d'être injuste mais d'être ferme avec
ceux qui mettent en péril notre société
et notre vie commune j'ai déposé une
proposition de loi ensemble dès qu'il y
a trouble à l'ordre public il faut que
cela emporte expulsion je propose
également de réviser les catégories
ouvrant droit une protection relative à
un absolu endurcissant les critères
l'immigration et l'affaire de tous et
nos territoires
ultramarins sont bien sûr concernés ma
collègue Estelle Youssoupha vous a
interpellé sur la situation de Mayotte
une situation qui est catastrophique
c'est un territoire dans lequel l'État
français perd le contrôle et l'urgence
est d'agir pour réasseoir notre sur
notre souveraineté
un deuxième volet le volet travaille
j'ai une position raisonnée sur ce sujet
complexe nous avons eu besoin de
l'immigration pour construire notre pays
une immigration qu'elle soit d'Europe
mais aussi d'Afrique et notre présence
tant à le confirmer sur le terrain il y
a beaucoup de chefs d'entreprises chez
moi dans les Vosges mais partout sur
notre territoire que ce soit dans le BTP
l'hôtellerie la restauration qui
viennent me voir qui viennent nous voir
car il y a un besoin de compétences il
ne s'agit pas de régulariser à tout va
mais de mieux cibler
j'ai la chance d'être député d'une zone
rurale où les entreprises sont
vertueuses elles ont en tête l'intérêt
commun il me paraît souhaitable de les
accompagner de penser à l'adaptation et
même l'aptaptabilité de politique sur
nos territoires il faut
départementaliser si nous voulons que
cela fonctionne cette réforme doit être
en cohérence avec nos réalités
territoriales de plus nous devons
balayer devant notre porte quand nous
compliquons les démarches et demandeurs
qui ont fait preuve de courage et d'un
investissement important pour nos
territoires j'ai notamment en tête
l'exemple de tous ces professionnels de
santé étrangers qui sont venus nous
aider dans le dans le cadre de la
pandémie du covid il nous était
indispensable et le son toujours contenu
des tensions du secteur et pourtant pour
certains je ne pense notamment deux
d'entre eux parmi les effectifs du
centre hospitalier de Remiremont ils
peinent à obtenir les autorisations
nécessaires pour rester et continuer
d'exercer pourtant nos hôpitaux ont
besoin d'eux et nous avons su avoir
besoin de
vous l'aurez compris j'appelle de mes
vœux à un projet de loi pragmatique pour
protéger les Français nos entreprises de
manière générale pour assurer la pleine
application de nos valeurs et nos
principes républicains ce n'est que de
cette façon que nous pourrons construire
une réponse cohérente au défi qui nous
attendent
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Ludovic Mendes
pour le groupe renaissance pour une
durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres monsieur présent
de la commission des lois mes chers
collègues
on ne peut avoir ce débat aujourd'hui
sans dire sans se dire que nous avons
ces dernières années beaucoup légiférer
sur l'immigration depuis 1986 ce ne sont
pas moins de 28 textes de lois que le
rassembler a examiné
certains ont répondu à des faits
d'actualité d'autres à des urgences du
quotidien jamais il doit aborder le
sujet dans sa globalité pour préparer le
long terme
ce qui a nourrit les haines alimentées
par des débats d'émotion accentués par
des faits divers mais sans jamais
apporter une réponse concrète et adaptée
on ne peut pas se permettre de laisser
le débat migratoire aux extrêmes d'un
côté les nationalistes avec leur
silencieux contre projet visant à
permettre l'expulsion d'un étranger quel
que soit le degré de gravité de la
menace qu'il représente sachant que pour
eux tout étranger par nature par
principe est une menace en devenir de
l'autre les populistes qui naïvement
seraient prêt à accueillir toute la
misère du monde en abandonnant tout
contrat à républicain et sans se soucier
des possible conditions d'accueil
c'est nationalistes
ces populistes poussent au radicalisme
communautaire
nous assistons à ping-pong politique
extrémiste dont le seul but est
d'exister de créer des peurs et infiner
se faire élire
voilà pourquoi il nous faut travailler
légiférer encore pour proposer un
nouveau projet républicain européen et
humanistes compris par l'ensemble de la
nation
républicain d'abord parce que c'est la
République qui protège chaque individu
sur son territoire et c'est là notre
honneur
de droit protège et offre un cadre qui
oblige par des devoirs celui ou celle
qui ne respecte pas les règles de la
République qui troublent l'ordre public
qui discrimine n'a pas vocation à se
maintenir sur la terre qui les accueille
nul ne peut violer notre pacte
républicain sans réponse adaptée
il nous est important de dire les choses
avec raison plutôt que dogmatisme sans
issue comme certains dans cette émission
même s'il peut y avoir des coombitants
statistiques entre une partie de
l'immigration et une partie de la
délinquance jamais on ne pourra accepter
d'entendre étranger égale délinquant car
ça ce n'est pas la République
nonobstant nous devons aussi reconnaître
la défaillance de notre système
d'accueil peut-on encore continuer de
centraliser la gestion administrative
dans certaines préfectures au risque
créer des files d'attente qui interroge
nos concitoyens la répartition
territoriale se pose et se posera encore
le cadre républicain nous demande de
dépolitiser le débat il nous oblige à
nous unir pour réussir parce que la
question migratoire est aussi un débat
technique le législateur doit tantôt
dépasser les flux tantôt objectiver le
stock il doit légiférer avec une main
tremblante mais déchiffrer le réel avec
une certaine froideur clinique l'ouvrage
est immense la tâche est targue mais il
ne doit jamais me semble-t-il perdre de
vue ce fond d'humanité qui aujourd'hui
et demain continue de guider notre rép
il nous faut améliorer l'efficacité des
procédures d'élogue allemand pour les
étrangers en situation irrégulière tout
en revoyant notre capacité de
régularisation de celles et ceux qui
présentent sous le sol national travail
et sont pleinement intégré à notre
société notre nation ne peut y répondre
seul c'est en européen européen
seulement que nous pourrions y arriver
en européen parce que les flux
migratoires sont tels que seuls une
réponse à l'échelle de notre continent
peut être efficace malgré tout nous
sommes confrontés aux défaillances de
l'Union européenne comme l'Accord
démontré le besoin d'accueil de la
chaîne Viking rejeté par la politique
nationaliste du gouvernement italien oui
l'Europe est défaillante elle attend
l'unanimité sur un sujet qui nous
obtiendra jamais il dévitable de trouver
un accord de solidarité il nous faut
agir en criminalisant les réseaux de
passeurs comme leurs complices et on
améliorant et améliorer les
relocalisation dans toute l'Europe des
personnes nouvellement arrivées pour
cela l'Union européenne ne peut attendre
encore davantage pour redéfinir le cadre
juridique du paquet asile
depuis plusieurs années sous l'effet des
inégalités de richesse des tensions
géopolitiques du réchauffement
climatique des réseaux de traite humaine
et du fondamentalisme religieux l'Europe
et gage de survie pour une partie de
l'humanité enfin l'humanité car nous
parlons d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
qui pourraient la plupart quittent leur
pays au péril de leur vie non sans
déchirement et sans projection de ce que
pourrait être leur futur
leur avenir sera notre si nous
redéfinissons les grandes lignes de
notre politique qui considèrent que
l'honneur de notre pays de pouvoir
continuer à assurer sa tradition
d'accueil néanmoins nous devons
renforcer la lutte contre la précarité
des étrangers présents en France qui est
plus forte que pour le reste de la
population et durablement plus
importante au fil des générations nous
devons aussi renforcer le parcours
d'intégration sauf à mettre à mal notre
pacte républicain et pour mieux intégrer
il faudra limiter les flux migratoires
dans le cas de nos engagements européens
internationaux mais aussi expulser plus
rapidement ceux qui n'ont pas leur place
sur le territoire national
la France pays des Lumières nation des
droits de l'homme et berceau de
l'humanisme ne laisse et ne laissera pas
mourir à ses portes ou sur son sol
celles et ceux qui souhaitent et qui
méritent de rejoindre son projet
républicain je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame pour le groupe
rassemblement national pour une durée de
5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
la première madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
au moment où cette Français sur dix
veulent revoir en profondeur notre
politique d'immigration j'aurais préféré
parler au vrai décideurs c'est-à-dire à
Madame vanderleyen présidente non élue
de la Commission européenne qui a
décrété que l'immigration massive serait
la solution à tous les mots mais
j'aurais aussi préféré parler aux
responsables des SOS Méditerranée qui
semble avoir plus de pouvoir pour
décider de qui débarque en France que le
ministre de l'Intérieur lui-même dans un
pays surendetté où l'on compte 5
millions de chômeurs ou un Français sur
4 ne mange pas à sa fin ces vagues
migratoires ne sont plus supportables
rendez-vous compte avec Emmanuel Macron
chaque année c'est l'équivalent de
presque deux fois la population de la
ville de Bordeaux qui arrive légalement
en France sans compter les 700 000
migrants illégaux selon le chiffrage de
Monsieur Darmanin lui-même cette
immigration anarchique livre les
Français à toutes les insécurités
l'insécurité physique tout d'abord en
effet les chiffres de vos ministères
indiquent que 81% des vols violents dans
les transports en Île-de-France sont le
fait d’étranger que 25% des détenus dans
les prisons sont des étrangers et que
75% des mineurs déférés devant le juge
sont des mineurs isolés étrangers et
sont d'ailleurs pour la plupart ni
mineur ni isolé mais les Français sont
aussi livrés à une insécurité culturelle
pendant certains quartiers
communautarisés d'autres coutumes
d'autres mœurs d'autres lois que celle
de la République française prévale enfin
l'insécurité financière quand on voit le
coup exorbitant de cette immigration que
vous imposez aux Français contre leur
gré comment accepter qu'en pleine crise
du logement seulement 12% des Français
habitent un logement social quand un
tiers des immigrés ont eux le droit
d'être hébergé dans un HLM c'est une
profonde injustice pour toutes les
Françaises et tous les Français qui
travaillent et qui attendent depuis des
années que leur dossier soit traité un
mot sur votre funeste projet de réforme
des retraites celui-ci risque d'être un
véritable massacre pour les pensions de
nos aînés alors que des étrangers n'ont
jamais qui n'ont jamais cotisé en France
perçoivent une retraite parfois bien
plus élevée qu'un certain nombre de nos
agriculteurs ou certains artisans qui
ont travaillé et cotisé toute leur vie
comment accepter madame la Première
ministre qu'au moment où à coup de 49.3
vous imposez un système de français dans
lequel un Français sur trois renonce aux
soins vous tolérer que des étrangers
clandestins qui ont violé nos lois pour
arriver ici bénéficie gratuitement des
largesses de l'aide médicale d'État qui
coûte au contribuable français plus d'un
milliard d'euros oui oui l'immigration
coûte un pognon de dingue les détenus
étrangers c'est plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros les mineurs étrangers
c'est un milliard d'euros le coût total
du financement de l'asile plusieurs
milliards d'euros et en même temps vous
dites aux Français et bien que eux ils
doivent se serrer la ceinture vous avez
fait un choix celui de la préférence
étrangère nous nous en faisons un autre
celui de la priorité nationale vous
faites le choix de la régularisation de
l'immigration nous nous faisons celui de
la régulation de l'immigration oui les
Français doivent être prioritaires pour
l'embauche oui les Français doivent être
prioritaires pour le logement oui les
Français doivent être prioritaires pour
les aides sociales mais ça
malheureusement vous ne le ferez jamais
il faut tout changer dans la politique
d'immigration car être accueilli en
France c'est un privilège cela se mérite
et cela serait respecte
d'interview en interview de déclaration
en déclaration monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur Darmanin vient nous
expliquer qu'avec lui l'immigration
incontrôlée et l'immigration clandestine
c'est fini ou bien encore que les
occultés vont être appliqués moi
j'entends d'ici le rire de l'imam IQ sen
et aussi ceux des 243 migrants de
l'océan de Viking dispersés dans la
nature sans aucun contrôle
vous avez fait le choix de faire de
notre pays l'hôpital l'hôtel le
restaurant et le Pôle emploi de tous
ceux qui ont décidé de s'y inviter
eux-mêmes dans votre France
libre-service tout le monde rentre tout
le monde se sert personne ne paye et
surtout personne ne repart cette France
all inclusive doit cesser les Français
doivent revenir mettre de leur destin et
choisir enfin qui vient chez eux et qui
reste
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Annie Genevard
pour le groupe les républicains pour une
durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
vous prétendez avoir la volonté d'agir
contre une immigration non maîtrisée de
plus en plus difficile à accepter pour
près de 70% des Français
permettez-nous d'en douter pour
plusieurs raisons simples première
raison Emmanuel Macron et ses
gouvernements ont la fâcheuse habitude
de promettre des lois très ambitieuses
mais de les traduire par des textes sans
effet quelques exemples la loi agile et
immigration de 2018 cette loi a élargi
la ville quand elle était censée la
réduire le nombre de mineurs non
accompagnés a été multiplié par 5 en 10
ans autre exemple la loi dite
séparatisme suite au discours très
offensif du président de la République
aux Mureaux en octobre 2020 elle s'est
transformée en un texte très faiblement
intitulé principes des respects de la
République qui n'a pas empêché un imam
radical visé par un arrêté d'expulsion
de narguer l'autorité de l'État français
depuis la Belgique dans une forme de
schizophrénie vous exprimez aujourd'hui
votre soutien aux femmes iraniennes qui
paient de leur vie leur respiration à la
liberté dont le voit et le triste
symbole après avoir refusé d'inscrire
dans cette loi l'interdiction du
voilement des fillettes j'en viens à la
deuxième raison qui nous fait douter de
votre détermination
c'est votre contradiction permanente
vous affirmez que vous serez un
traitable sur l'immigration illégale
mais vous accueillez le géant de Viking
ce navire vous le savez n'est que
l'éclaireur des passeurs qui font
commerces de la vie humaine et une fois
arrivé à bon port en France les
passagers clandestins ont disparu dans
la nature
troisième raison qui nous conduit à ne
pas croire vous promesses votre tendance
à masquer une impuissance incapable
d'exécuter les auqtf le président de la
République promettait 100% de réussite
des occultés F on en est à moins de
6%. incapable d'exécuter les écouterf
vous avez inventé la régularisation pour
cause de métiers en tension vous espérez
que nous confondrons cette disposition
avec l'application des quotas
d'immigration mais cela n'a rien à voir
les quotas correspondent à une capacité
de choisir une immigration légale et
qualifiée en fonction des besoins
auxquels ne peuvent répondre les
demandeurs d'emploi français votre
proposition c'est la régularisation
d'une main d'oeuvre non qualifiée entrée
clandestinement en France alors que tant
de Français non qualifiés sont
indemnisés car sans emploi ce n'est pas
un choix c'est premier à subir une
situation que vous ne pouvez résoudre
cet argument économique ne tient pas
vous prétendez que les chefs
d'entreprise vous le réclament vous les
écoutez mal ce qu'ils veulent c'est
embaucher et voir le chômage diminué les
patrons sont aussi des citoyens qui
croient davantage au travail qu'elle
assistance l'argument économique n'est
qu'un écran de fumée pour dissimuler le
gage offert à votre aile gauche
tirons les enseignements du passé
la flux de main d'oeuvre immigrée non
qualifiée dans les années 70 à engendrer
à urbanisme déshumaniser ces ensembles
sont devenus le terreau des trafics et
du communautarisme on ne dirige pas un
pays à coup d'injonction contradictoires
on ne peut pas conduire en appuyant en
même temps sur le frein et
l'accélérateur aujourd'hui votre
gouvernement madame la Première ministre
est à la croisée des chemins en la
matière le en même temps est impossible
mon collègue Pierre-Henri Dumont voula
dit soit on encourage les migration
clandestine soit aussi oppose
l'encourager tout en disant si opposé
c'est l'encourager poser un texte clair
et précis sur la table au lieu de
répéter les mêmes débats sans effet
cessez de repousser ce moment de vérité
pendant que vous nous faites débattre
une fois de plus car ce n'est pas le
premier débat
400 000 étrangers sont autorisés en
France chaque année soit l'équivalent de
la population de Montpellier
l'impuissance de l'action publique
exaspèrent les Français et nous savons
où conduit cet exaspération ou conduit
l'exaspération en politique il n'y a pas
d'état sans fermeté c'est autorité n'est
pas à géométrie variable elle vaut
vis-à-vis des immigrésilégaux mais aussi
pour faire respecter nos valeurs
communes madame la Première ministre
vous avez le choix entre le courage et
le renoncement pour notre part les
républicains nous avons toujours fait le
courage le choix du courage dans la
clarté sachez que nous continuerons
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin Haddad
pour le groupe renaissance pour une
durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre Mesdames et Messieurs
les mini chers collègues nous
examinerons en début d'année prochaine
un texte pour réformer et renforcer
notre système d'asile et d'immigration
notre majorité s'empare de ce débat sans
tabou sans complexe et avec des
principes clairs notre pays a toujours
été une terre d'accueil et d'immigration
avec des besoins économiques ainsi qu'un
devoir humanitaire cette tradition à
nourri notre pays son histoire sa
littérature et les bancs de tous les
parties de cette assemblée soyons en
fier notre continent européen entier est
confronté à défi migratoire nourri par
l'instabilité politique le dérèglement
climatique et la transition
démographique dans notre voisinage ces
défis exigent des réponses communes à
l'échelle européenne mais en parallèle
de ce devoir d'accueil nous devons faire
respecter l'autorité de l'État les
étrangers sont aujourd'hui sur
représentés dans les actes délinquance
19% des vis en cause pour des faits en
général sont étrangers quand ils ne
représente que 7,7% de la population de
trop nombreuses obligations de quitter
le territoire ne sont aujourd'hui pas
exécutés nos concitoyens nous
interpellent tous les jours à ce sujet
et nous leur devons un discours de
vérité et de responsabilités face à ces
défis nous avançons avec une logique
d'équilibre de droits et des devoirs
faciliter l'intégration par la langue le
travail de ce qui viennent paisiblement
contribuer à vivre notre pays et assumer
la plus grande fermeté face à ceux qui
ne respectent pas nos règles un
équilibre face aux outrances de
l'extrême droite qui est toujours vu
dans l'étranger une menace qui agitent
la peur et veut faire croire que nous
pouvons nous barrer qu'à des anneaux
frontières nationales un équilibre face
au laxisme et la démagogie l'extrême
gauche qui pense que nous pouvons nous
passer de frontières que la France peut
accueillir toujours plus sans jamais
rien exiger
oui nous devons maîtriser notre
immigration un pays souverain a le droit
de choisir qui rentre sur son territoire
dans définir les critères d'accès
d'insertion les besoins économiques et
d'expulser ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester sans cette maîtrise notre
politique migratoire nourrirait un
sentiment d'impuissance celui de
l'immigration subit et non choisie cette
maîtrise dans le cadre de la démocratie
et de l'État de droit c'est la condition
de l'accueil de l'intégration mieux
contrôler pour mieux accueillir
l'inverse c'est le populisme de la
fermeture irréaliste et contraire à nos
valeurs et nos traditions que propose
nos adversaires au cœur de notre projet
se trouve le travail nous faciliterons
l'obtention et le renouvellement des
autorisations de travail en définissant
nos besoins ces métiers en tension qui
donneront accès à des titres de séjours
pour les étrangers déjà sur notre
territoire nous aiderons à la sortie de
la trappe à inégalité nous
sanctionnerons aussi plus durement les
entreprises faisant recours au travail
légal et pourquoi ne pas aller plus loin
en regardant ce qui se fait ailleurs
face à la compétition internationale
pour les talents les Canadiens les
Américains qui attirent une immigration
qualifiée avec le permis à points ou le
H1B les cartes vertes ou le travailleur
doit démontrer qu'il a des compétences
spécifiques qu'un Américain n'a pas mais
aussi en corollaire peut-être réfléchir
à des plafonds quantitatifs votés par
notre assemblée comme certains de nos
voisins européens Autriche Italie au
Portugal nous devons soutenir
l'apprentissage de la langue en
conditionnant la délivrance d'un titre
de séjour à la maîtrise d'un niveau
minimal de français apprendre la langue
respecter les institutions connaître
notre histoire c'est une garantie pour
soi-même et les générations futures
l'intégration se mérite elle demande un
engagement fort du nouveau venu je ne
serai pas sur ces bancs sans les efforts
le travail de mes grands-parents qui
n'ont jamais oublié la reconnaissance
qu'il devait à la France qui les a
accueillis alors qu'ils fuient
l'antisémitisme avec deux bébés dans les
bras dans mon père
complément de l'intégration la fermeté
les étrangers en situation régulière
ayant commis des infractions graves doit
pouvoir être expulsé après avoir purgé
la peine des détention il nous faudra
réformer contentieux des étrangers
aujourd'hui trop long trop complexe
augmenter les places encras pour mieux
exécuter les auqtf et faciliter à
l'inverse les démarches de ceux qui
restent c'est une question de bon sens
notre majorité peut être fier de son
bilan c'est cinq dernières années nous
avons doublé les contrôles aux
frontières intérieures augmenter les
capacités de rétention accentuer la
pression sur les pays de retour
augmenter les éloignements pour trouble
à l'ordre public ou radicalisation les
délais d'Asie sont aujourd'hui alors
plus bas depuis 12 ans nous avons
renforcé les moyens d'intégration et les
exigences pour les naturalisations notre
pays est l'un des plus attractifs pour
les étudiants étrangers au niveau
européen la France est la première à
porter la réforme de Schengen et de
Dublin 3 et le renforcement des moyens
de Frontex pour contrôler nos frontières
mais nous le savons la tente de nos
concitoyens est forte pour aller plus
loin face aux nouvelles réalités des
dernières années nous aurons dans les
prochains mois à débat dans lequel
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres vous pourrez
compter sur notre soutien sur notre
détermination pour co-construire avec
vous et toutes les oppositions à un
texte ambitieux et pérenne pour notre
pays merci beaucoup je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
bourlange président de la commission des
affaires étrangères pour une durée de 5
minutes
ça ne marche pas
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame la
ministre étrangère messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
ce débat est évidemment important car
une réflexion sur l'immigration est au
cœur de notre réflexion sur nous-mêmes
sur notre histoire sur notre identité
sur notre place dans le monde le premier
constat adressé c'est que les flux
migratoires qui ont fortement augmenté
au cours des dernières décennies
continueront à croître au cours des
prochaines années
ces flux migratoires
ont trois origines qui doivent être
clairement distinguées si l'on veut
mener une politique cohérente ils sont
d'abord et en profondeur
liés à notre histoire comme le rappeler
le président de la République
l'immigration est au cœur de la vie de
la nation celle des deux derniers
siècles en tout cas en France le
développement industriel n'a pas été
réalisé comme ailleurs par l'exode rural
mais par les vagues successives
d'étrangers que nous avons fait venir
les Belges celui-philippe les Italiens
sous le Second Empire et la Troisième
République les Polonais entre les deux
guerres les Ibériques sous la Quatrième
République les Africains pour
l'essentiel après
reconnaissons la dette que l'une des
premières puissances industrielle du
monde doit aux immigrer qui ont pris une
part décisive et sachons voir aussi
accessoirement si je puis dire que le
regroupement familial est d'abord la
contrepartie d'un service rendu par ces
populations par ces immigrés à notre
développement
ces flux sont en second tour en seconde
pour une bonne part
excusez moi motivé par une demande
légitime politique mais aussi économique
et maintenant climatique de protection
internationale si c'est flux se sont
amenuiser pendant la période
d'épidémique que nous avons connu il
marque maintenant une lettre crudescente
ces situations doivent être gérées
solidairement sur le plan national et
sur le plan international comme l'avait
fortement souligné dans son magnifique
rapport il y a quelques années ma
prédécesseur Marielle de sarnaise
l'accueil sur le territoire national est
une option parmi d'autres l'aide à
l'installation des immigrés ailleurs
qu'en France constituent une autre
option mais elle appelle également un
effort qualitatif et quantitatif et
financier de solidarité ne pas
accueillir chez nous ce n'est pas ce ne
doit pas être se désintéresser mais Mutu
les efforts d'intégration c'est
d'ailleurs le fondement de l'aide au
développement
troisièmement et là c'est plus délicat
il y a un effet pervers de ce que nous
avons de meilleur
l'attractivité sociale de notre modèle
nous ne pouvons nous permettre
d'accueillir l'ensemble des volontaires
à l'immigration simplement parce que
c'est mieux chez nous sans créer alors
une situation structurellement
déséquilibrée chez nous comme dans
l'ensemble du monde cela nous devons les
aider à vivre là où ils sont en leur
donnant les moyens de vivre dignement et
c'est là que se fonde la nécessité
souvent méconnue d'un contrôle des flux
migratoires par l'État
face à ces vastes mouvements de
population les États comme la France
s'efforent de répondre à deux exigences
la maîtrise administrative des flux la
qualité humaine sociale et culturelle de
l'intégration et là ces petits que dans
la France d'aujourd'hui nous sommes
encore bien loin du compte serait-il
illusoire de prétendre maîtriser
l'accueil le séjour l'intégration le
renvoie parfois de centaines de milliers
de personnes on est tenté de le croire
au vu de certains indicateurs par moins
d'une trentaine de lois en réformés la
législation relative aux étrangers
depuis
1980 le faible taux d'exécution des
décisions de renvoi ou encore l'inconnu
pesant sur le nombre d'étrangers en
situation irrégulière entre 500 000 et
700 000 donnent le sentiment d'une
terrible impuissance en la matière en
2015 la Cour des comptes pointait
l'absurdité d'un système complexe et
coûteux d'examens de la demande d'asile
qui aboutit au maintien de 96% des
déboutés sur le sol français
ce débat est de plus en plus ce débat
est le plus surplombé par la question
européenne et par le devoir de
solidarité avec les États du premier
entrée on ne peut pas créer une
communauté humaine sans frontières et
des politiques nationales d'immigration
cloisonnées et fragmenté quant à
l'intégration il est clair que le modèle
est à reconstruire qu'il s'agisse j'ai
presque fini de l'accès à la langue au
savoir au logement à la sécurité à
l'emploi tout est réinventé c'est
pourquoi nous saluons madame la Première
ministre nous saluons votre initiative
vous avez un immense travail devant vous
nous ne vous demandons qu'une chose
c'est de voir grand
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Fadila Khattabi
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales pour une durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci bien madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues la question de
l'immigration est une question qui doit
être débattue et ce pour plusieurs
raisons tout d'abord telle est la
volonté des Français mais celle-ci doit
être débattue avec sérénité objectivité
et humanité et ce d'autant plus que la
France est considérée de par le monde
comme le pays des Lumières le pays des
droits de l'homme il faut le dire
quitter son pays sa famille ses amis et
peu importe les raisons qu'elle soit
économiques ou politiques n'est jamais
chose facile d'ailleurs l'exil est très
souvent vécu comme un déchirement une
souffrance
la question doit être aussi débattue
afin d'éviter à ce qu'elle soit
instrumentalisée à des fins
électoralistes avec des propos
nauséabonds comme l'immigration de
remplacement qui relèvent du complotisme
plus que de la réalité l'histoire de
notre humanité a toujours été parcouru
par cette question et notre époque ne
fait pas exception bien au contraire le
21e siècle et sera le siècle des
migrations mais attention à bien
préciser préciser ce dont nous parlons
car en la matière l'amalgame n'est
jamais très loin et ses regrettable en
effet j'aimerais rappeler à celles et
ceux qui ont trop souvent tendance à
l'oublier que nous parlons bien
aujourd'hui des personnes immigrées
arrivées récemment sur notre territoire
et non de nos concitoyens qui sont issus
de vagues migratoires antérieures et qui
désormais font partie intégrante de
notre communauté nationale je dis bien
intégrante oui mes chers collègues on
intègre pas les enfants de la République
cela ne veut pas dire que l'intégration
n'est pas un objectif louable bien au
contraire en effet il nous faut repenser
certes nos politiques de contrôle mais
aussi notre modèle d'accueil et donc il
nous faut à nouveau légiférer dans le
contexte actuel que traverse notre pays
avec un taux de chômage encore
persistant et ce malgré une reprise de
notre économie grâce à la politique
volontariste du gouvernement la question
de l'immigration
revêt une importance majeure notamment
ce qui concerne l'intégration
professionnelle des travailleurs
immigrés repenser notre modèle
d'intégration républicaine cela passe
aussi par des dispositifs en faveur de
l'emploi de la formation qui pourront
trouver une place je l'espère dans le
prochain projet de loi que nous
discuterons au sein de notre assemblée
oui je suis favorable à la création d'un
titre de séjour métier en tension en
effet faciliter l'insertion
professionnelle des étrangers c'est
aussi faciliter leur insertion sociale
mais c'est également donné à nos
entreprises une solution face à
l'impasse je le sais mes chers collègues
nous sommes toutes et tous interpellés
sur nos territoires par des
entrepreneurs en grande difficulté de
recrutement obligé parfois de fermer
leur établissement ou de réduire leur
activité en effet faut-il encore le
rappeler on dénombre près de 400 000
emplois non pourvu dans notre pays
mettant en difficulté des secteurs
entiers tels que l'hôtellerie
restauration l'agriculture le transport
ou encore le médico-social parce que le
travail est un vecteur incontestable
d'intégration et d'émancipation j'espère
mes chers collègues que vous soutiendrez
également certaines mesures visant à
mettre fin à des injustices je pense
notamment à la fin du délai de carence
qui empêche les demandeurs d'asile de
travailler pendant leur six premiers
mois en France pour éviter également que
des employeurs peu scrupuleux profit une
main d'oeuvre clandestine il faut
permettre à ces travailleurs étrangers
de pouvoir être régularisé cette
proposition je le souligne constitue une
demande récurrente des syndicats enfin
et surtout n'oublions pas la jeunesse
l'accès à la formation en particulier au
travers de l'apprentissage constitue
pour les jeunes apprentis étrangers un
tremplin essentiel vers leur intégration
future
aussi je suis convaincue qu'il nous faut
davantage garantir la fluidité de leur
parcours en tant qu' ancienne enseignant
dans un CFA j'ai rencontré à de
nombreuses reprises des chefs
d'entreprise désespérées de ne pouvoir
embaucher définitivement leur apprenti
qui était pourtant motivé et compétent
faute de délivrance d'un titre de séjour
lors de leur passage à l'âge adulte ces
injustices contre-productives pour notre
pays et notre tissu économique ne
doivent plus se reproduire vous l'aurez
compris mes chers collègues la politique
de l'immigration est intrinsèquement
liée à politique de l'emploi comme notre
politique économique aussi au-delà des
interrogations que nous focalisons
toujours autour des chiffres et des
questions sécuritaires j'espère que ce
débat permettra d'ouvrir notre réflexion
plus largement en nous incitant à ne pas
perdre de vue que nous parlons ici avant
tout de femme et d'hommes qui pour la
plupart d'entre eux contribuent au
développement de notre pays
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
ce n'est pas une charge je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Sacha oulier
président de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
République pour une durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame messieurs les ministres
chers collègues le monde n'en finit plus
de donner tort au théoriciens de la fin
de l'histoire la chute du mur de Berlin
marque l'ouverture des frontières mais
elle coïncide également avec la
fermeture des esprits à l'avènement
d'une crise passion identitaire des
nations et de leur peuple face à la
disparition des grandes idéologies
politiques les repères se sont
progressivement effacés les questions
sur ce qu'ils font de la Nation se sont
renforcés dans ce contexte le rapport à
l'étranger à celui qui diffère c'est
foncièrement dégradé pourtant la France
fut et demeure une terre d'immigration
et sans rappeler l'histoire compter par
le président bollange en sentant
l'histoire contemporaine ce sont les
voisins européens que nous avons
accueilli et protéger de leur tyran
c'est les ressorts ce sont les
ressortissants des anciennes colonies
d'Afrique et du Pacifique que la France
a ouvert ses portes
en comptant sur leur main d'oeuvre pour
maintenir l'avenir du pays mais la
réalité c'est que l'Europe entière c'est
redit devant les difficultés
géopolitiques du monde face au
terrorisme et face aux guerres elle est
aujourd'hui paralysée par des mécanismes
de solidarité abscons comme le règlement
Dublin par les égoïsmes et les
démagogies nationalistes les citoyens
européens ressentent collectivement un
puissant malaise autant devant les
images de l'exode des réfugiés dans les
Balkans que lors de la découverte du
corps du petit ellan sur une plage
grecque
cette tétanie c'est aussi emparée de la
France qui déplore autant l'accueil
massif qu'elle conjure en même temps sa
prétendu inhumanité nous ne pouvons
rester sans voir ce grand dérangement
nos lois ont pourtant tout consacré le
principe de l'accueil dès la
constitution de l'un et plus tard bien
plus tard grâce à la ratification de la
Convention de Genève nous sommes
organisés pour reconnaître la protection
aux exilés tout comme pour admettre le
séjour temporaire ou définitif des
étrangers sur notre sol à mesure que les
difficultés économiques et sociales se
sont à monselées notre système légal
apportant été dépassé en même temps que
l'ascenseur social la machine à intégrer
ces grippées
il a su représentation des étrangers
dans les actes de délinquance commis
principalement dans les métropoles à
accrue les tensions de notre société dès
2018 nous n'avions pourtant prisé devant
en acroyant la protection aux femmes
étrangères victimes de violence ou
menacées d'excision nous avions acté le
schéma de répartition des demandeurs
d'asile l'entreprise simplifier les
procédures renforcer les mesures
d'intégration des immigrés nous avions
aussi donné à la France les outils qui
lui permettent aujourd'hui d'être le
pays européen qui pratique le plus de
reconduites à la frontière
le réalisme et l'honnêteté pas
unanimement partagé dans cette hémicycle
nous oblige à reconnaître que beaucoup a
été fait et qu'il reste beaucoup à faire
d'ailleurs la commission des lois se
penchera bientôt sur les conditions
d'accueil de l'océan Viking dans une
mission flash que nous venons de décider
sans prétendre à l'exhaustivité nous
savons que nos préfectures croulent sous
les demandes que les instances de
l'asile comme les juridictions
administratives sont à la peine que les
procédures demeurent détournées mais
aussi que l'effort de milliers de
travailleurs n'est pas reconnu sur ces
sujets il nous faut des réponses
il appartient donc à la représentation
nationale de dire simplement mais
définitivement que des réponses plus
systématiques doivent être apportées il
appartient à affirmer que la France n'a
pas vocation à accueillir celles et ceux
qui violent ces lois et ses règles et
que les procédures d'expulsion doivent
impérativement les concerner il nous
revient aussi de sortir d'une incroyable
hypocrisie qui consiste à compliquer la
vie de celles et ceux qui étrangers
travailleurs en France rendent service à
la nation je demande donc au
gouvernement la régularisation de ces
salariés exerçant dans les métiers en
tension au moyen d'une procédure de
plein droit sans dépendre de leur
employeur cette régularisation
améliorera leurs conditions de travail
et plus globalement celle de leur métier
comme celle de l'ensemble du salariat le
travail nous rassemble le travail nous
lie jamais les droits des travailleurs
étrangers ne seront à opposer à ceux des
travailleurs français dans nos
entreprises
grâce à ces mesures plus systématiques
les préfectures et les juridictions qui
devront nécessairement être profondément
revu selon les conclusions des rapports
du Conseil d'État et du Sénat gagneront
en efficace en efficacité comme en
humanité
dans les débats qui s'ouvrent je vous
demande également de ne pas céder au
mode comme aux solutions simplistes qui
aggravent les problèmes plutôt qu'elles
ne les résolvent je dis mon hostilité au
quota qui trop nombreux ou insuffisant
ne satisfont jamais personne je dis mon
opposition au quota qui parle arbitraire
d'un chiffre autoriserait le séjour
indus ou interdirait un accueil mérité
la démocratie adulte doit pouvoir parler
d'immigration mais elle ne peut répondre
au malaise populaire que si elle accepte
de regarder l'immigration en face en
sanctionnant les abus tout en
reconnaissant les mérites je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre-Alexandre Anglade président de la
commission des affaires européennes pour
une durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre madame la
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues au terme de ce long
débat que je voudrais porter devant vous
une conviction simple il n'y aura pas de
réformes nationales efficace sans une
approche européenne des phénomènes
migratoires et il n'y aura pas de
réponse durable sans l'adoption du pacte
asile et immigration nous pouvons avoir
tous les débats que nous voulons les
plans d'action les réunions de crise en
européen nous serons en pleinement
efficaces qu'en agissant à 27 pourquoi
l'approche européenne est-elle une
nécessité elle est d'abord car l'absence
de frontière intérieure au sein de
l'espace Schengen nous rend
inévitablement dépendant des politiques
migratoires des autres États membres et
particulièrement de leur gestion des
frontières extérieures de l'Union elle
est une nécessité aussi parce que les
migrations sont une réalité mondiale qui
trouve leurs sources dans des facteurs
globaux cela a été rappelé maintes fois
dans le débat et donc la coopération
avec les pays tiers de départ ou de
transit ne peut trouver que plus de
force si elle est portée au niveau
européen plutôt que par des initiatives
nationales isolées
elle est une nécessité enfant car de
nombreuses difficultés que nous
rencontrons aujourd'hui dans l'Hexagone
sont et découlent des faiblesses du
cadre européen je pense notamment à
l'importance des mouvements secondaires
de demandeurs d'asile Didier alors que
les arrivées de migrants et de réfugiés
sur le sol européen repartent à la
hausse dans un contexte géopolitique
instable 90 000 migrants pour l'année en
cours rien qu'en Méditerranée centrale
une réponse européenne est possible face
à la flux de réfugiés le plus important
depuis la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale déclenché par l'agression russe
en Ukraine l'Union européenne a montré
qu'elle pouvait agir efficacement avec
l'activation en mars 2022 du dispositif
de protection temporaire
mais il s'agit d'une exception il faut
l'admettre depuis la crise de l'accueil
des réfugiés de 2015 les États membres
de l'Union européenne ont présenté trop
souvent un front des Unis le refus par
l'Italie en violation de tous les
principes de droit d'accueillir le crâne
Viking on constitue un nouvel et
regrettable exemple comme a pu être le
refus de la Hongrie et d'autres pays en
Europe de toutes seules
ces divisions et les faiblesses de notre
politique commune remettent en cause
l'État de droit en matière d'asile avec
des réfugiés des migrants qui se
retrouvent pour certains à la rue dans
des parcs et des abris de fortune et
dans le même temps ces divisions
européennes nous affaiblissent
collectivement en ce qu'elles remettent
en cause notre souveraineté en nous
rendant vulnérable aux tentatives de
déstabilisation de régime pour certains
autoritaires lesquels n'ont pas de
scrupules un instrumentalisé des
situations humanitaires dramatiques
comment Libye ou comme l'a montré
l'attaque hybride orchestrée par la
Biélorussie avec le soutien de la Russie
aux frontières restes de l'Union à
l'automne dernier
par ailleurs notre incapacité à nous
entendre collectivement sur la question
des frontières et la prise en charge des
demandeurs d'asile fragile fragilise
aussi notre édifice démocratique en
faisant le jeu de l'extrême droite en
Europe du rassemblement national en
France qui n'ont rien d'autre à proposer
que le repli d'identitaire au mépris des
vies humaines qui se brise en
Méditerranée et nous savons que si nous
répondons collectivement au défi
migratoire en respectant nos valeurs et
notre droit nous leur enlèverons leurs
principales carburant électoral qu'a
proposé le rassemblement national dans
le débat de ce jour rien si ce n'est la
politique du refoulement et de la
violence qui en dit long sur leur projet
migratoire qui consiste par cynisme à
laisser dériver en mer les migrants et
les réfugiés à criminaliser les ONG qui
protègent des vies le tout en expliquant
que la véritable humanité serait la
fermeté cynisme et mépris pourquoi c'est
pourquoi nous avons mes chers collègues
plus que jamais besoin d'une approche
européenne commune et harmonisée des
politiques migratoires et d'intensifier
nos efforts pour permettre l'adoption de
la réforme du cadre européen
pour laquelle les effets de nos
politiques nationales demeureront
nécessairement limité c'est ainsi que
nous pourrons bâtir une politique
européenne équilibrée entre nos valeurs
humanistes et de solidarité à l'égard
des réfugiés mais aussi des pays de
première entrée et un contre l'effectif
de nos frontières extérieures pour
prévenir l'immigration illégale je tiens
ici à saluer les avancées permissent par
la présidence française de l'Union
européenne sur ce sujet en plus des
progrès obtenus sur les négociations des
textes de législatif du pacte la France
a joué un rôle moteur en permettant
l'adoption d'un mécanisme volontaire de
relocalisation par très État membre ce
mécanisme traduit en acte la solidarité
européenne par la prise en charge des
demandeurs d'asile est constituent une
première étape avant la création d'un
mécanisme similaire de solidarité
obligatoire dans le cadre de la réforme
du pacte mes chers collègues je le
répète l'Union peut-être la clé pour
surmonter les difficultés que nous
rencontrons sans naïveté mais dans le
respect de nos valeurs d'humanité et
dans un juste équilibre entre
responsabilité et solidarité européenne
et ayant conscience que nous sommes en
bien meilleur position pour faire face
aux défis migratoires qu'en 2015 et 2016
nous avons des ressources nous avons des
instruments et nous avons désormais la
volonté politique et donc nous devons
plus attendre pour nous doter d'un cadre
de migration européen à l'épreuve du
temps et qui ne répondent pas simplement
à l'urgence des navires qui arrivent sur
nos côtes les solutions sont ici à
portée de main nous pourrons le faire et
nous le ferons j'en suis persuadé c'est
le rôle de la France de le porter avec
plus de force encore à Bruxelles je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministres de la justice
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés
pendant que nous travaillons sur ce
texte
il y a deux jours un polémiste dont les
Français n'ont pas voulu
nous a dit que
parmi les raisons qui faisaient que nous
connaissions la délinquance il y avait
je le cite
ethnique que connaissait notre pays
c'est un de vos anciens amis
vous êtes séparés il y a de cela
quelques semaines
CCI de ont applaudit Monsieur B monsieur
Collard vos anciens amis
il y a peu de temps qu'ils vous ont
quitté et vous les avez supporté
longtemps et puis il y avait également
l'une de vos nièces si j'ose dire
applaudissement nourri comme on dit sur
les comptes-rendus alors il y a
à l'évidence la France des Lumières et
puis la France de l'obscurité pour ne
pas dire la France de l'obscurantisme et
c'est dire que il faut être fier de
porter le projet que nous allons porter
Madame Le Pen vous l'avez entendu
un discours raté d'une certaine façon
car elle ne propose rien Certes papa
sera très content ce soir mais pour le
reste disons-le il n'est pas question
pour elle de travailler sur ces
questions parce que c'est au fond
mettre à néant le théorème qu'elle porte
depuis bien trop longtemps
les étrangers sont la cause de tous nos
mots et s'attaquer à la question comme
nous souhaitons le faire avec lucidité
sérieux c'est évidemment désastreux pour
elle parce que elle perdrait au fond
elle perdrait au fond elle perdrait au
fond son ADN madame Diaz je vous réponds
tout de suite
d'abord d'abord
vous évoquez le Parlement européen et
madame ourseula vanderleyen je voudrais
vous dire qu'au Parlement européen vos
amis ont surtout brillé par leur absence
sachez-le quand même et vous aussi
d'ailleurs et et je pense que d'aucun
vous le reproche au demeurant oui mais
je souffrais souffrez que Madame que je
vous réponde ensuite vous nous asseyez
comme d'habitude des contre-vérités que
dites-vous
chers
vous dites que les logements sociaux
sont donnés aux étrangers certainement
pas à ceux qui sont en situation
irrégulière ça n'est pas possible et ça
n'est pas vrai vous évoquez ensuite la
délinquance des étrangers cette votre
fantasme naturellement laissez-moi
terminer elle existe il faut le regarder
lucidement mais je voudrais vous dire
que dans les autres pays européens cette
délinquance elle existe et je voudrais
vous faire une toute petite remarque
vous y réfléchirez si vous le voulez
vous savez mon impératif m'est interdit
lorsque je m'adresse à vous mais les
juges souvent exigent des garanties de
représentation notamment en matière de
détention provisoire et par définition
les étrangers n'en n'ont pas et c'est
une des raisons qui explique qu'il y est
une forte détention provisoire des
étrangers
ensuite
j'en viens maintenant à madame genvarge
je savais que je vous respecte
l'infiniment madame la députée je vous
ai connu je vous ai connu je vous ai
connu mieux inspiré et je rappelle que
c'est monsieur le Président Sarkozy qui
a touché au double peine vous nous
donnez aujourd'hui des leçons vous ne
dites un certain nombre de choses et que
et que et que et que avec courage et
lucidité nous évoquerons ces questions
bien sûr parce que elle mérite
c'est pénible c'est pénible vous savez
elle mérite elle mérite de l'être un
dernier mot un dernier mot et je termine
c'est madame la Première ministre je le
confesse à fleur de faux je prends la
parole je pense évidemment au généralouf
qui a libéré la Sicile un Marocain je
pense au groupe Manoukian j'adore cette
formule français de préférence je pense
à Joséphine Baker je pense à tant
d'autres et plus proche de nous je pense
à ceux qui travaillent qui sont ici qui
sont dans notre pays qui veulent
travailler et qui méritent qu'on les
regarde avec considération et attention
et humanité je veux dire à Monsieur le
Député Pierre-Henri Dumont que les
étrangers il est parti et je le regrette
ne sont pas une charge
mais c'est un propos d'une infinie
violence et non madame genvar je vous en
supplie je vais aller très vite
ma mère qui a 86 ans
qui a quitté son pays d'origine où elle
crevait de faim elle a travaillé toute
sa vie je pense que si elle rencontrait
monsieur Pierre-Henri Dumont en dépit de
la forme que lui accorde son grand âge
elle lui courrait après avec le balai
dont elle s'est servi toute sa vie car
elle était technicienne de surface
naturellement je la retiendrai dire que
les étrangers qui travaillent sont une
charge c'est un scandale absolu c'est
d'une violence insupportable et moi
voyez-vous je veux remercier la première
ministre je veux remercier mon ami
Gérald Darmanin Olivier du soft
Catherine Colonna
pour leur dire quoi
mais oui mais Franck sur ce projet là en
particulier mais je le remercie aussi
parce que je l'aime beaucoup voilà merci
tout le monde mais je veux leur dire que
vous allez enfin nous permettre
de nous rappeler collectivement
que le mot étranger n'est pas le
synonyme du mot délinquance et pour cela
merci
alors
les délinquants voyez-vous nous allons
les traiter avec la fermeté qui convient
Gérald Darmanin dit tout à l'heure que
nous allions criminaliser les passeurs
nous allons également simplifier les
procédures qui sont trop complexes nous
allons être efficaces et sans aucune
complaisance à l'encontre des étrangers
délinquants voyez-vous moi je reprends à
mon compte cette formule la France on
l'aime ou on la quitte et je l'assume
ensuite il y a les autres les
travailleurs monsieur
Pierre-Henri Dumont il faut qu'il mette
ses actes en conformité avec ses paroles
et quand il est dans un VTC qu'il
demande qui le conduit et qu'il saute
tout de suite du véhicule et quand il va
dîner dans un restaurant qu'il demande
tout de suite qui a fait la cuisine et
quand il mange un fruit qu'il demande
qu'il l'accueillit parce que c'est une
réalité qui est incontestable vous voyez
ce projet il a du sens c'est du en même
temps en même temps on s'occupe des
délinquants et en même temps on s'occupe
de ceux qui bossent et dont on a envie
dans notre pays parce qu'ils font la
richesse de notre pays alors je termine
j'ai plus rien à dire mais quand même je
ne résiste pas je ne résiste pas au
plaisir de vous lire un tout petit texte
ça va aller très très vite écoutez si
vous le voulez bien
confortablement ces immigrés ils seront
donnés à leur village cette turbulence
cette malpropreté qui les caractérise
c'est pas un papier de valeur actuelle
c'est un papier de
du 18 mai 1935 paru dans le journal la
lumière et vous savez qui on parle on
parle d'héritage des sales macoranis
j'en ai un autre il y a 50% de
travailleurs on parle des Italiens qui
font le jeu des patrons en acceptant et
en sollicitant même du travail
supplémentaire voulez-vous s'il vous
plaît être le messager de ses propos
auprès de messieurs jacobelli et de
Monsieur Bardella vous me feriez plaisir
merci
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et les outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
merci la présidente peut-être quelques
mots de réponse à mon tour aux orateurs
peut-être à Monsieur Vallot il n'est pas
là mais de là où il est de nous entendre
lui dire que peut-être sur la question
un peu dure sur pourquoi ça marche pas
dans la préfecture j'aurais aimé qu'il
puisse faire son son propre mais à culpa
puisque c'est bien sous le gouvernement
de François Hollande qu'on a supprimé
une très grande partie des agents de
préfecture que l'un derrière la cour de
comptes et c'est nous qui réparons
désormais ce drame en remettant des
agents de préfecture qui peuvent
justement bien accueillir les étrangers
donc je crois que là quand on chante la
vérité on la chante pas à moitié
camarade ce serait une bonne chose à mon
avis de de dire ce qu'il a dit
d'ailleurs en incipit de son
intervention qu'il faut avoir un
discours simple honnête et en plus de
vérité je crois que oui je crois que on
lui fera le passager mais à part cela on
pouvait être d'accord sur une partie de
ces de ces propositions
sur la question des immigrés clandestins
ça a été dit par beaucoup de gens ici et
notamment par le rassemblement national
bien sûr mais aussi par les républicains
je veux juste dire de mots à Madame
Genval et à Monsieur Dumont en 2004 il y
a eu 105 y avait 151000 étrangers en
situation régulière au sens où ils
étaient inscrits à ce qu'on appelle la
me qui est le meilleur moyen sans doute
je cite Patrick Stéphanie de voir
combien d'étrangins se sont annuaire il
y a sur le sol national en 2017 donc
deux quinquennat passées il y en a eu
315000 on est passé de 151000 à
315000 étrangins se sont agréés en deux
quinquennats avec une même progression
d'ailleurs à peu près ce de quelqu'un là
une petite accélération sur Monsieur
Hollande enfin c'était quand même le
vrai évidemment sous le quinquennat du
président Sarkozy pour plein de raisons
d'ailleurs pour des raisons de
difficultés du monde que nous comprenons
tout à fait un peu déjà les réfugiés
climatiques parfois la démographie ce
qui a été évoquée mais aussi par un tas
de qui était déstabilisé a commencé par
la Libye bien évidemment et puis sous le
président Macron on est passé 315000 à
360 000 c'est vrai que ça augmente mais
ça augmente si vous faites le calcul 8
fois moins que sur les deux quinquennats
précédents et quand vous nous reprochez
après de vouloir régulariser ce terme
faut mais on aura le débat parlementaire
pour le dire des personnes qui sont
depuis cinq ans sur le territoire
national qui travaille pardon même jeune
homme mais nous régularisons des
personnes qui sont rentrées sous les
quinquennats précédents pas pour ceux
qui sont arrivés il y a trois oui il y a
4 ans puisque ne serait-ce que la
circulaire valse c'est 5 ans
d'ancienneté sur le territoire national
et on fait 30 000 régularisations par an
donc oui on régularise c'est vrai mais
on le fait pour tous ceux qui sont
rentrés voilà déjà plus de 10 ans sur le
territoire national et vous le savez
très bien et je pense que si on veut un
débat il y a moins de monde dans
l'hémicycle désormais plus personne ou
moins de monde nous écoute mais si on
veut un débat s'insérer sur un il faut
qu'on dise aussi la vérité des prix et
la vérité des prix c'est que par
ailleurs sous le quinquennat du
président Macron le Soudan l'Afghanistan
la ça a été des pays qui se sont
rajoutés aux difficultés des demandes
d'asile par exemple et je crois que
c'est pas très honnête la façon dont
vous avez présenté les choses et je peux
me permettre un jeune Var on aura
l'occasion sans doute de reparler dans
le débat mais en tout cas la comparaison
est prêt on est prêt à comparer toutes
les comparaisons je pense qu'elle ne
sont pas très favorables au test que
vous défendez sur la question des
aucutés f là aussi entre 2007 et 2012
le nombre de qtf qui ont été mis c'était
60 000
et les exécutés c'était 12000 c'est à
dire que sous le caca du président
Sarkozy on exécutait 19% des qtf nous
nous sommes à 15% des occultés F
exécutés pour la période 2017-2022
sachant qu'on a eu deux années où il y a
pas de transport aérien où il y avait le
covid donc c'est pas facile d'expulser
ces personnes quand on est entre 15 et
19%, je pense qu'il y a pas de leçon de
morale à donner je crois à cette tribune
je pense que vous n'avez pas plus
expulsé nous n'avons pas plus expulsé à
l'époque que maintenant pour des tas de
raisons très compliquées qu'on pourrait
d'ailleurs améliorer mais je pense que
ce serait mentir je crois aux électeurs
et aux habitants de dire que il y a 5
ans il y a 10 ans on savait expulser que
depuis le président Macron on sait pas
le faire oui donc vous êtes exactement
dans un pourcentage que nous étions
madame genvar et je pense qu'il faut
regarder en plus la vérité en face il y
avait l'époque même des départs aidés
vous le savez très bien de gens qui
étaient payés et qui revenaient trois
mois après avec le pécule vous avez
arrêté ça sous la fin du quinquennat
donc mais c'est pas très il faut qu'on
le compare et il faut voir qu'est-ce
qu'il doit changer fondamentalement et
c'est ce que nous proposons d'ailleurs
dans le texte de loi que qu'on vous
présentera vous dites on attend de voir
ce texte de loi mais les débats
présentés par la première ministre ici
au Sénat sont des débats qui ne sont pas
pour rien puisque nous n'avons pas
encore transmis nos écritures au Conseil
d'État nous attendons la fin des débats
et des consultations d'ailleurs je crois
que nous voyons bientôt votre groupe
politique la semaine prochaine me
semble-t-il à Bobo avec le ministre du
Travail et on écoutera évidemment toutes
les propositions
je voudrais dire et Madame la promesse
la cité que l'essentiel des propositions
que nous mettons sur la partie de lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière de non
régularisation justement des personnes
qui sont sans titre de séjour de retour
dans les pays d'origine viennent du
rapport buffet nous avons fait je veux
réussir les coupables mais il y a pas
droit d'auteur nous avons fait un
copier-coller du rapport buffet pour une
très grande partie de cette disposition
donc non ce n'est pas vrai il en est
d'accord il en est d'accord d'ailleurs
on écoutera avec l'intérêt président
buffet au Sénat puisque nous arrivons
toujours à travailler je crois de bonne
intelligence avec le CA soient ces
questions encore une fois je pense que
la comparaison
pas elle est pas elle n'est pas
l'avantage enfin j'ai pas compris votre
chiffre de 400 000 qui était
manifestement cité par Monsieur Dumont
et par vous-même
non oui oui j'ai compris votre calcul
mais il est c'est un double titre votre
vous dites ouais il y a 400000 personnes
qui vendent comment payer chaque année
qui s'accumule bon d'abord c'est c'est
faire de drôle de calcul puisque ces
400000 personnes c'est quoi c'est 270
000 de titres de séjour 70 000 nouveaux
200000 renouvelés alors si déjà la
moitié de 400 000 c'est 200000 titres
renouvelé de titre de séjour long
des gens qui sont sur le territoire
national qui ont déjà eu un titre de
séjour long et qui donne le
renouvellement donc en fait votre
proposition c'est donc de ne pas le
renouveler donc les 20% de médecins qui
sont dans nos hôpitaux non mais madame
madame Genval vous nous dites vous
faites accueillir un grand titre de
journal une équivalent d'une ville comme
Montpellier chaque année comme si ils
remplacement arriverait c'est moi c'est
présentation est n'est pas très zone
n'est pas très honnête vous avez vous
avez dit chaque année une ville comme
Montpellier qui arrive on a l'impression
que quelque chose de terrible va nous
arriver je veux redire pour tout le
monde comprenne que sont les 400 000
titres de séjour 200 000 sont des titres
de séjour renouvelés donc ce qui serait
intéressant de savoir c'est pas
simplement des gens que vous ne voulez
plus accueillir mais les gens ne
voulaient pas renouveler vu le nombre de
lettres des parlementaires et notamment
LR que je reçois pour absolument
renouveler des types de séjour je pense
que vous n'avez pas tous d'accord
manifestement sur cette première
question la deuxième question c'est les
70 000 nouveaux entrants la question
peut se poser sur ces nouveaux entrants
vous avez tout à fait raison la question
c'est qui sont ces personnes vous savez
bien que sur ces 70 000 20 ans il y a
plus de la moitié familiale et je veux
dire aux Front national notamment Madame
Le Pen qui a dit quelques âneries à la
tribune de l'Assemblée le ruban le
roulement familial le regroupement
familial c'est 13% d'immigration
familiale c'est-à-dire extrêmement
affinitésimal et sur l'immigration
familiale c'est les conjoints de
Français les conjoints français déjà
pour une partie d'entre eux ce sont des
Européens est-ce qu'on doit interdire
aux Européens de venir avec leur épouse
vous l'aurez poux deuxièmement et oui
quand vous êtes à français et que vous
mariez avec quelqu'un d'autre au bout
d'un certain temps et avec des critères
vous avez le droit d'être
en regroupement familial qui interdit
ici à un français de pouvoir faire venir
sa femme qui vient de l'Asie du Maghreb
ou des États-Unis personne donc d'abord
plus la moitié de cette immigration est
l'immigration familiale doit-on la
restreindre c'est une question
intéressante que va évoquer le projet de
loi c'est et là on peut être d'accord
avec un centre de disposition nous
souhaitons qui est beaucoup plus
d'immigration économiques qui est des
Mig
c'est vraiment pour faire le chiffre
rond de 400 000 et pour coller à
Montpellier parce qu'il y a 120 000
demandes d'asile et après vous voulez
vous rajoutez les 30000 pour faire vos
400 000 de gens qui ont eu l'asile donc
double compte les 120 000 demandeurs
d'asile madame Genval ils ont le droit
l'Asie on doit étudier je pense pas que
le groupe les républicains
non mais on doit pouvoir étudier on peut
avoir étudié leur dossier on doit
pouvoir étudier leur dossier même je ne
Var et même même rapidement mais on doit
pouvoir l'étudier d'ailleurs le texte
que nous proposons propose de l'étudier
rapidement ce que d'ailleurs aucun
gouvernement n'avait proposé auparavant
je vous le signal et vous le savez très
bien et c'est parfois très compliqué
parce qu'il y a des conventions
européennes et il faut que nous
regardons les choses avec intérêt et
nous on est prêt à regarder
l'amélioration des visas pour demande
d'Asie dans les pays d'origine on l'a
fait notamment pour une partie des
Afghans c'est ce que nous faisons avec
les Afghans les Afghans de Turquie
demandent le demande d'asile en France
et nous exception pas tous sur le
territoire national mais sur ces 120 000
madame il y a 30000 puisque vous
rajoutez 30 000 pour attendre 400000 qui
sont à 120 000 puisque c'est eux qui ont
à la fin un asile donc en fait votre
chiffre 400000 est pas très sérieux
alors on peut toujours discuter de
savoir si on doit supprimer des titres
de séjour comme l'a dit Laurent Marc
Angeli dans son intervention on peut
toujours en discuter ce qu'on doit
mettre des cottages j'ai entendu ce
qu'elle dit présent de la commission des
lois on peut toujours en discuter enfin
je crois que si on veut sur un sujet
extrêmement difficile je pense que le
mieux c'est quand même pas des chiffres
qui ne correspondent pas à la réalité
la parole
est un train
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires européennes
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
vous ai tout d'abord remercier les
oratrices les orateurs et les
parlementaires présents aujourd'hui
sans surprise malheureusement nous avons
entendu plusieurs interventions de pure
postures de pure démagogie et parfois de
pure mensonges sans aucune proposition
en particulier du côté du rassemblement
national qui a pu reprendre au mot près
les discours qui ont une bonne
cinquantaine d'années et je ne relève
pas non plus que le discours de la
présidente pano parle d'un projet qui
n'est pas celui du gouvernement elle
lance des saillies sur des sujets que
j'ai précisément écarté j'en viens à
croire que les insoumis voudraient
vraiment s'en tenir à un tête-à-tête
avec le rassemblement national en lui
parlant comme s'il était au gouvernement
je ne vais donc pas m'attarder plus
longtemps les ministres ont eu
l'occasion de mettre en lumière les
contradictions les contreérités que
contenait certaines interventions je ne
vais pas alimenter des débats qui se
fonde sur des peurs et non pas sur la
réalité des débats qui se font sur des
polémiques et non pas sur des solutions
en revanche j'ai entendu et c'est ce que
je veux retenir parmi les groupes de
l'arc républicains des constats communs
et des propositions utiles
au-delà des clivages nous partageons une
volonté d'agir directement sur les
causes de l'immigration illégale en
accompagnant les pays de départ et de
transit en mettant notre aide au
développement au service de la lutte
contre la pauvreté et le dérèglement
climatique ensuite nous voulons que
notre droit soit respecté et que les
délais des procédures soient raccourcis
là encore je pense qu'une majorité peut
se dégager au sein de l'arc républicain
pour poursuivre ses objectifs
enfin et c'est l'objet je pense d'un
quasi consensus sur ses bancs nous
voulons mieux intégrer celles et ceux
que nous accueillons notamment par le
travail et par la langue mesdames et
messieurs les députés j'en suis
convaincu notre politique migratoire est
un équilibre un équilibre
hérité d'une histoire portée par des
valeurs et respectueux de l'État de
droit un équilibre entre le respect
ferme de la loi et l'intégration franche
de ceux à qui nous accordons le séjour
et l'asile un équilibre je suis certaine
que nous pourrons trouver ensemble je
vous remercie
merci madame la Première ministre le
débat est clos prochaine séance ce soir
à 22h suite du projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable la séance est
levée